I open my MacBook, type a session password, hit return, nothing happens.
I realized that the password field is not in focus.
I click on it and then I pass.
I type the pass again and it works and the focus was on Slack.
And I just sent my session password to the whole team.
What the fuck?
The best answer to this tweet was,
from someone who changed their password,
that looks like a greeting.
Hey there, guys.
Sehr schön. Also passiert es mir das noch nie,
aber das darf halt auch nicht passieren.
Das denke ich mir jedes Mal,
du kannst bei KDE,
du hast halt manchmal
um was anderes fokussiert, wenn du dich einloggst,
wenn du dich einloggst,
ein Button oder sowas,
dann kannst du tippen, also das denke ich mir jedes Mal.
Irgendein Fenster hat jetzt das Passwort gekriegt.
Also wenn du bei,
beziehungsweise du kannst ja eigentlich
bei fast allen
Desktop-Umgebungen sowieso immer
die Tastatur mitlesen.
Eigentlich gibt es kein sicheres System, wo das Passwort fällt.
Das einzige ist, was das Passwort kriegt, was du gerade eintippst.
Aber so, wenn du ein Tool bist,
was vielleicht so aus Debugging-Gründen Tastaturzeuges mit tippt,
was in seinem Fokus passiert nur,
dann fängst du halt Passwörter ein.
Da habe ich auch mit gelernt auf Wacker News,
dass Windows das tatsächlich sehr richtig macht.
Oh, warte.
Okay, erzähl und dann erzähl ich, was ich kenne.
Da läuft wohl der Login, also auf aktuellen Windows.
Früher war das tatsächlich noch viel witziger,
weil da konntest du den Login-Dialog wegkanceln
und einfach dein Taskmanager wegschießen.
Und dann war der weg und dann warst du da.
Aber ich glaube, das war 1995 oder so.
Aber aktuell funktioniert der Anmeldeprozess
und die UI dafür auf einem extra Desktop,
die sehr strikte Rechte hat,
dass da keine andere nicht-Microsoft-Applikation
die UI hinmalen darf und da empfangen darf.
Und das ist ein sehr valider Weg, damit umzugehen.
Okay.
Also es gab zumindest vor anderthalb Jahren mal einen Vortrag von zwei Studenten an dem Sicherheitslehrstuhl hier bei uns,
die gesagt haben, ja, wir haben einfach mal hier das neue Windows 10 genommen
und da einfach mal ein paar Zertifikate reingetan,
dass wir die SSL-Verbindung, die das Ding nach Hause aufmacht, mitlesen können.
Und dann haben sie einfach mal ein normales Windows 10 weiterbetrieben
und geschaut, was das so nach Hause funkt.
Aber gerade bei Windows 10 ist ja bekannt, das macht richtig viel Scheiß.
Home Edition funkt irgendwie dreimal so viel nach Hause
wie die Professional Edition.
Und was sie festgestellt haben, ist,
wenn du dein Passwort falsch eingibst
bei Windows beim Login,
dann wird das im Klartext,
also per SSL,
aber das Passwort selber im Klartext
an Microsoft geschickt.
Und zwar aus den Gründen,
dass du dich ja mit einem Microsoft-Account
einloggen könntest.
Und wenn du dein Passwort irgendwo änderst und den Computer zum ersten Mal wieder aufmachst
und dann dein neues Passwort eingibst, dann überlegen sie,
naja, das Passwort könnte ja falsch sein, weil du gerade bereits dein neues Passwort eingibst.
Deswegen schicken wir das mal nach Hause, um zu schauen, ob das ein neues Passwort ist.
Geil.
Nein.
Also immer genau aufpassen, was du tippst.
Oder am besten Face Recognition anmachen.
Oh Gott, ist das dumm.
Ach übrigens, wollen wir anfangen mit Podcasten?
Ja, gerne.
Hi Kilian.
Hey Hendrik.
Lange nichts gemacht?
Ja, wir haben schon eine Weile irgendwie
geschafft, das ungewollt aufzuschieben.
Wir schreiben jetzt Anfang Dezember
und die letzte Folge war Folge 10.
Ich dachte, wir können jetzt so tun, als ob die Folge
im Oktober aufgenommen wird.
Ich war es.
Disclaimer. Wir haben leider diese
vergessen zu veröffentlichen.
Aber jetzt müssen wir auch
drauf schauen, dass die Themen nicht zu neu sind,
die wir jetzt ansprechen.
Ja, wir sind einfach, was das angeht, ein bisschen unzufrieden.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr uns trotzdem noch hört.
Wir machen das ja auch hauptsächlich
so für uns zum Spaß.
Unsubscribest du Podcasts, die lange nicht gepublished haben?
Oder kriegst du es einfach nicht mit und hast die weiterhin subscribt?
Es gibt ein, zwei Podcasts,
wo ich mir denke, ach, die könnten mal wieder
was Neues machen.
Party zum Beispiel ist.
Die haben schon ewig so erstmal gemacht.
Und dann gibt es aber auch Podcasts, da überlege ich
die zu unsubscriben.
Weil sie mir echt auf den Keks gehen.
Also es gibt... Aber die bringen was raus.
Ja, die bringen was raus. Was sie rausbringen,
da denke ich mir, boah, ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitgelesen hast.
Ich habe mit dem
Macher von dem New Rustation Podcast
hin und her geschrieben. Ach so, Chris Kreitchow.
Und das ist ja auch
so ein Typ, also der
macht den am professionellsten,
aber auch irgendwie nervigsten Rust-Podcast.
Inwiefern nervig?
Insofern nervig, als dass er am Anfang,
der spielt halt seine Melodie
und dann macht er halt ganz viel so Boilerplate-Gelaber
und zum Schluss erwähnt er alle seine Patreon-Sponsoren.
Weißt du, Karl Rüther?
Ich gebe den Namen an.
Ich habe das für dich gelernt bei diesem Podcast.
Ja, und er betet das halt runter jedes Mal.
Auch beten ist schön, gerade bei ihm,
weil der Typ ist ja sehr, sehr religiös.
Das ist, glaube ich, so ein Christi, ja.
Und der hat jetzt, so ähnlich wie wir,
so eine Interview-Geschichte gemacht.
der war beim Rust Belt
Rust Belt Rust Fest
nee, Rust Belt Rust
Kongress
und hat da einzelne Leute interviewt.
Und hier, da mal einen und das war teilweise,
ja ich mach so ein bisschen Rust in der Firma, mir haben sie gesagt, ich soll das machen
und das waren so zwei Minuten Interviews.
Aber die Interviews dauern halt
wirklich so zwei, drei Minuten und es kommt vorher
dieses Boiler-Play-Zeugs und es kommt hinterher
dieses Boiler-Play-Zeugs und dann bin ich dann das letzte Mal
du denkst dir wirklich
oh Gott, jetzt kommt das, jetzt muss ich schon wieder spulen.
Da habe ich dann echt mal geschrieben,
die letzte Folge
Neura Station besteht
zu 30% aus Inhalt,
zum Rest aus Boiler Blade.
Das ist voll nervig. Da hat er noch ein bisschen geschrieben,
ja, aber ich möchte doch meine ganzen Patreon-Leute
irgendwie erwähnen,
weil die geben mir schließlich Geld.
Und ich glaube, da hat hier Vincent oder so,
irgendwer von, ich glaube, das war Vincent,
von HelloSwift
nochmal eingechimed
und gesagt, ja, ich muss Hudi dazu
stimmen. Das geht schon irgendwie ein bisschen.
Die Leute zahlen dir doch nicht dafür, dass du ihren Namen
vorliest oder sowas. Ja, wenn es halt
mit drinstehen dann auf Patreon. Aber gerade bei den
Folgen, ich muss sagen, diese Serie
von, also normalerweise höre ich den sehr, sehr gerne, weil die auch
sehr informativ sind. Ja, der macht das eigentlich auch ziemlich gut.
Aber diese Serie von diesen
Kurzinterviews, die habe ich jetzt durchgelöscht, weil
das war so inhaltslos.
Also der hat gesagt, ich möchte
da, dass jeder Einzelne im Rampenlicht steht
mit den Interviews, aber ganz ehrlich,
das ist überhaupt kein Flow,
da dir drei Minuten so ein bisschen gelabert
zu hören, das macht eher Spaß, wenn du dir die alle hintereinander
Das ist auch kein Content. Das ist einfach nur so wirklich, ja, was machst du?
Und du so, ja, ich mach nicht wirklich viel, ein bisschen das und das.
Ah, cool, dass du hier bist. Ja, das war die Folge.
Ja, genau. Wow.
Also es waren, glaube ich, ein, zwei interessante, aber das ging irgendwie dann.
Also es muss nicht unbedingt sein.
Ich weiß auch nicht. Aber ansonsten, wie gesagt,
das macht ja jetzt echt einen großartigen Podcast.
Ich wollte auch nochmal vom Vorlauf was zu Anfang anfangen,
weil gerade die ersten Folgen, wo quasi Stück für Stück
eins Besonderheiten von Rust durchgeht und Syntax-Elemente und Features
und sonst was wirklich sehr detailreich
erklärt. Das war echt richtig große Klasse.
Ja, der hat dann auch ein richtiges Skript dafür
geschrieben und das dann abgearbeitet. Das hat er schon
ziemlich gründlich und gut gemacht.
Ist halt ein typisch amerikanischer Podcast
mit. Ich nehme hier Geld ein mit
und mache Werbung. Ja, aber es hat auch
ein hohes Production Value für einen Podcast. Das muss man wirklich sagen.
Ja, also ich glaube, wir bräuchten hier nicht mehr Werbung.
Nee, bestimmt nicht.
Aber der Typ ist auch wirklich
ein bisschen komisch. Ich glaube, das hatten wir sogar
in einer unserer frühen Folgen schon mal kurz angesprochen.
Also gerade diese, also ich will ja
über irgendwen hier hinwegziehen, aber
der ist mir ein bisschen zu religiös.
So ein bisschen creepy religiös.
Das war, weil er
irgendwie gepostet hat, dass er seine Kinder
irgendwelche Bibelstellen lesen lässt.
Seine Tochter muss die Bibel auswendig lernen.
Was? Das ist super komisch.
So unangenehm.
Ja, das ist halt
hier unser aufgeklärt
atheistisches Kulturbild,
was wir haben, was wir glaube ich auf andere Leute
nicht applizieren dürfen.
Ich weiß nicht, ich bin da auch ein bisschen
ein bisschen vorsichtiger sein. Ich finde,
Kinder mit in die Kirche
nehmen oder sowas, in sowas reinführen, das ist
als ob du Kinder zu Parteiversammlungen
mitnimmst oder sowas. Das ist was, wo
Kinder nichts von haben und
einfach bloß, damit die das schon früh
mit der Muttermilch aufnehmen und sich
ja keine eigene Meinung bringen. Das ist doch eine Vorwollindoktrination.
Ja.
Jetzt haben wir unsere Meinung
auf R gesagt.
Verdammt.
Gut, dass er
es nicht versteht.
Das ist fast ein bisschen peinlich.
Ach naja, eigentlich
ist es ja ein dufter Typ und ich habe dem schon
ein, zwei Mal auf Twitter
ein bisschen Kritik zu seinem Podcast geschrieben,
aber nur weil ich halt sonst den Podcast eigentlich wirklich
gerne höre. Konstruktive Kritik.
Ja, also diese Interviewserie,
wer hätte wirklich davon profitiert,
wenn das zu einem, und es gab ja,
wenn er es zu einer Folge zusammengeschnitten hat,
die CPP-Cast-Leute hatten auch
so eine Interview-Folge mal gemacht,
wo es auf dem
CppCon-Leute interviewt haben
und da macht es einfach zwischendurch Piep
und dann kommt der Nächste, so wie wir das jetzt beim letzten Mal
gemacht haben. Das Konzept kommt mir doch fast bekannt vor.
Haben die bestimmt von uns abgeschaut.
Hast du mal ein bisschen Feedback bekommen
zur letzten Folge? Bloß, dass sie echt gut gewesen ist.
Ja. Also,
danke für das Feedback an euch da,
ihr Hörer.
Wir haben ja irgendwie ein, zwei Wochen
später war dann
diese Medienkunstgeschichte,
da sind wir nochmal hin,
zu den technischen Sammlungen.
Wir wollten uns da treffen und dachten,
wir gehen jetzt mal in dieses Tonstudio nochmal rein
und nehmen da was auf.
Aber es geht halt wirklich nicht,
dass du mal eben hingehst und sagst dir, hallo,
da haben wir mal eine Telefonnummer bekommen
und gesagt, wenn du das vorher anmeldet oder sowas,
lässt dich da bestimmt jemand rein.
Aber ich glaube, wir werden es jetzt nicht machen aufgrund der Tatsache,
dass es vielleicht ein bisschen
Overhead produziert.
Wahrscheinlich werden die nächsten Folgen jetzt wieder mit dieser
Audioqualität produziert werden.
Sie sitzen gerade bei mir in meinem Zimmer.
Ich hoffe, es heilt hier etwas weniger als im ASCII.
Im ASCII haben wir doch schon ein bisschen heilt.
Wir müssen mal was schaffen.
Diesmal haben wir es tatsächlich ein bisschen geplant gehabt,
also so wenige Tage.
Aber der Ben von Halo Swift
wollte uns mal sein Mikro ausleihen.
Hey Ben, vielleicht kriegen wir da mal eine bessere Audioqualität.
Ich hatte neulich mal überlegt,
dass ich mir so ein kleines Aufnahmegerät kaufe,
was du so hinstellen kannst.
Aber ich glaube, im Endeffekt wird das wahrscheinlich
die gleiche Quali haben wie das Aufnahmegerät,
was ich hier jetzt legen kann.
Von dem, was ich bisher gehört habe,
gerade von der Firma Zoom,
dieses H2 oder die ganze Reihe von den Geräten,
die sind echt richtig, richtig gut.
Also das ist bedeutend besser als aktuell,
was wir machen. Aber die kosten
halt auch ein bisschen Geld. Ich liebe euch seit keine
5-6 Jahren mit so einem Ding.
Brauchen wir da bloß eins oder müssen wir uns da
irgendwie so Headshots umsetzen?
Das Ding ist ein dediziertes Mikro mit
Aufnahmegeregern. Das Problem, was wir auch
haben, ist, wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel am Tisch sitzen und
wir beide so Laptops aufnehmen und der eine so rumhackt,
dann wird das halt mit aufgenommen. Ich hätte irgendwie überlegt,
wo wir vielleicht irgendwas nehmen könnten, wo wir beide uns
Headsets aufsetzen. Ja, also das Problem
Wir sind gefühlt der einzige Podcast, den ich kenne,
der jede Folge quasi mit allen Leuten vor Ort aufnimmt.
Alle anderen nehmen dezentral auf,
oder zumindest zu 90% dezentral,
und können deshalb jedem vor sein eigenes Mikro setzen
in unmittelbarer Entfernung.
Da klingt auch jeder in einem anderen Raum.
Das hört man auch häufig.
Aber das klingt halt auch,
gerade wenn man diese unmittelbare Entfernung zum Mikrofon hat,
bedeutend besser.
Und wir sitzen halt immer um den Tisch,
oder jetzt gerade um den Hocker.
Die Folge nackt,
Die war mit Jupp im ASCII aufgenommen.
Da habe ich mir echt Mühe gegeben,
ein paar Headsets auszuleihen von Leuten.
Und da hatte dann jeder sowas um von uns.
Und dann haben wir rumgefrickelt.
Und dann hat der USB-Hub, den wir angeschlossen haben,
nicht genug Power gehabt, um die ganzen Geräte zu versorgen.
Das ist immer ausgefallen.
Da mussten wir eins ausmachen.
Und Jupp hatte dann seins so umgemacht,
dass er die ganze Zeit reingeboostet hatte.
Er hat nur irgendwie drei Spuren,
davon konnte ich irgendwie, oder vier,
davon konnte ich irgendwie zwei verwenden.
Und dann musste ich hin und her schneiden mit Reaper.
Und im Endeffekt war es dann sogar so,
Teile der Aufnahmen, weil ich glaube, ich habe
was mit dem Telefon gemacht, das war mit
noch am besten.
Und die Aufnahmen, die wir
mit Reba gemacht hatten, die liefen mit einer anderen
Geschwindigkeit ab. Das heißt, ich musste irgendwie alle paar Minuten
nachjustieren.
Du musst halt wirklich über dieselbe Soundkarte aufnehmen.
Du hast einen minimalen Drift, das kriegst du nie raus.
Das ist richtig, richtig schlimm so was.
Ja, das ist komisch.
Also,
wir haben gerade mal nachgeguckt,
beziehungsweise ich muss mal
nachschauen, wann wir
unsere erste Folge eigentlich gemacht haben.
Wie lange machen wir denn das jetzt überhaupt schon?
Soundcloud slash akronomisierbar.
Du meinst, wie lange schaffen wir es schon nicht,
von Soundcloud wegzukommen?
Aber die Seite ist oftmals noch erreichbar.
Noch leben die aus irgendeinem Grund.
Akronomisierbar.
0, 0, 0.
0 Nummer.
Vor 10 Monaten.
Krass.
Das heißt, wir haben eine höhere Frequenz
als eine Folge pro Monat.
Minimal höher.
Wir haben es echt drauf.
Wir müssen es mal ein bisschen anziehen.
Am Anfang haben wir noch gesagt, wöchentlich.
Das wäre schön gewesen.
Dann wären wir jetzt irgendwo bei Folge 40.
Da hätten wir jetzt schon fast, ja.
Krass.
Stell dir vor, wir hätten 40 Folgen.
Könntest du dir vorstellen, dass die Leute 40 Folgen akronomisierbar annehmen?
Ich wüsste nicht mehr, über was für 40 Folgen reden sollten.
Passiert so viel überhaupt?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe heute eine Folge Bike Chat gehört.
Das ist ja auch ein sehr guter Podcast,
den wir bestimmt schon zwei, drei Mal erwähnt haben.
Da haben sie auch gemeint,
am Anfang haben wir uns voll Sorgen gemacht,
dass wir überhaupt nichts zu erzählen haben on air.
Deswegen haben wir uns irgendwelche Themen bereitgelegt.
Aber das machen wir jetzt mittlerweile gar nicht mehr.
Wir wissen, dass es einfach so funktioniert.
Die sind auch echt ein guter Laber-Podcast.
Die sind ein guter Technik.
Aber da können auch beide anfangen,
einfach mal von Arbeit zu reden.
Das geht bei uns leider nicht so richtig.
Also ich glaube, ich darf nicht von Arbeit reden.
Ich habe nichts von Arbeit zu reden.
Ja.
Und die werden dann halt auch sehr technisch detailliert.
Ich meine, wir können auch gerne ein bisschen technisch detailliert werden.
Aber wir machen nicht 100 pro die gleichen Technologien.
Das Coole bei denen ist halt,
ich mache absolut nichts mit Rails,
mit Ruby gar nicht, aber mit Rails erst recht nicht.
Und die labern halt eigentlich nur über Ruby und Rails.
Und es ist trotzdem unglaublich spannend.
Auf jeden Fall.
Und Active Record und Diesel und was die so machen.
Boah, echt zwei coole Typen.
Die haben Ahnung von dem Scheiß.
Ja, ansonsten nochmal, um auf diese Retro zurückzukommen,
zur Datenspurenfolge.
Also, ich hatte extrem viel Spaß mit dem Schneiden.
weil deswegen haben wir auch ganz viel von diesen kleinen Schnippeln da zwischendurch getan.
Ich hoffe, das hat nicht zu viel genervt.
Also ihr könnt uns gerne mal schreiben, ob das genervt hat oder nicht.
Ich fand es einfach hauptsächlich witzig.
Ja, von dem, was ich bisher von Leuten gehört habe, dass wir das echt gut hingekriegt haben.
Also wir hatten ja wirklich Spaß.
Wie lange haben wir gebraucht?
Ein paar Stunden, um das zusammenzufrickeln alles?
Ja, vielleicht sogar ein bisschen länger.
War witzig, mit Pause dazwischen.
Also ich meine, ich will uns jetzt hier nicht unnötig bauchstreichern.
Ich finde, wir hatten extrem viel Glück an dem Tag, dass wir das hingekriegt haben,
dass da Leute in diesem Studio waren.
Das war cool, das war richtig cool.
Das hat richtig fehl's gemacht.
Und das war ein paar Leute gekriegt haben,
die uns auf Rede und Antwort gestanden hatten
und uns ein bisschen Themen gespendet haben.
Ich habe seitdem ziemlich oft am Fenster gehört.
Ja?
Wie guter Titel.
Wir hatten jetzt Firmenweihnachtsfeier.
Und da hatten die auch irgendwie
zwei Musiker angestellt,
die sich so irgendwie solche Pappmachiköpfe
aufgesetzt hatten und die
die Sackos bis über den Kopf
zugezogen hatten, sodass du nur diese Pappmachiköpfe
aufhatten,
gesehen hast. Und die haben sich dann
gegenseitig mit irgendwelchen sächsischen Zeugs zugelabert
und die ganze Zeit dann irgendwie Musik gespielt.
Irgendwie mal mit Quetschkommode, mit Gitarre, mit Benjo,
mit Geige. Und der eine hat so
einen ollen Koffer gehabt, wo er mit so einem
Bass-Pedal, mit so einem Bass-Drum-Pedal
drauf rumgeklopft hat.
War ziemlich frickelig. Und das Letzte, was die gespielt haben,
war am Fenster.
Zu zweit. War gruselig.
Mit Gitarre. Und der andere auf der Geige hat die
Geigenstimme echt akkurat
notengenau
runtergespielt. Das war
bis dahin, das haben sie fast ein bisschen zu lange gemacht.
Die Leute haben dann fast angefangen, sich zu langweilen.
Wo die ersten paar Stücke ganz witzig waren.
Aber dann das letzte, was sie gespielt haben, war am Fenster.
Und das war nochmal richtig geil.
Nicht schlecht.
Irgendwann sind sie rausgegangen
und haben sich ihre Kostüme ausgezogen.
Da habe ich dann nochmal Tschüss zu denen gesagt.
Das hat kaum jemand gesehen.
Du hast gesehen, dass das so zwei Alt-Rocker waren.
Die waren, keine Ahnung, Ende 50,
hatten lange Haare und Schnurrbärte.
Das war sehr witzig.
Auf jeden Fall.
Nicht schlecht.
Hast du eigentlich schon Kongress-Tickets?
Klar, du auch, oder?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich habe gestern
diese E-Mail bekommen mit der Bestätigung, dass ich mir das jetzt
herunterladen kann. Sehr cool. Ich finde es immer cool,
das ist glaube ich seit letztem Jahr oder so, dass man
direkt diese Apple Wallet App
und Google Passbook
wie das heißt, oder verdreht.
Ich glaube, ich fuhr hier genau bei sich, was ist andersrum.
Dass du direkt darüber rein übernehmen kannst als digitales Ticket.
Cool. Finde ich witzig. Aber ich habe meistens
bei so Veranstaltungen, wo du bloß den
QR-Code hinzeigen musst, einfach bloß
das schnell mal die E-Mail aufgemacht und
hingehalten hast. Ja, aber ich mag jetzt tatsächlich
Wallet-App zu nutzen und da drin einfach coole Dinge zu sammeln.
Aber was macht die? Das ist einfach bloß
eine Art Scrapbook für PDFs, oder?
Ja, von der Idee her,
dass es halt keine PDFs anzeigt, sondern halt
explizit Dinge in deren Format, also
in diesem Apple-Wallet-Format.
Aber die meisten, also gerade Fluggesellschaften
unterstützen das eigentlich alle. Die Deutsche Bahn
kann das seit einer Weile. Ich sammle da drin
eigentlich einfach cool,
also zum einen Reisen-Tickets und
Veranstaltungstickets, weil es einfach schön ist, einfach mal durchzuscrollen
in der mittlerweile recht langen Liste.
Wie heißt die Variante für Android?
Ich, früher etwas gab ich Google Wallet
und jetzt Passbook, aber da gebe ich mich nicht drauf fest.
Ich glaube, das heißt... Ich habe überlegt, ob ich mir
mal sowas besorge, aber ich dachte mir, naja.
Weil iOS ist halt drauf, von Haus aus.
Ich bin ja jetzt auch ein, zwei Mal wieder geflogen
und da habe ich auch von der Flugzeugwirtschaft
das per E-Mail einfach aufgemacht.
Beziehungsweise kriegst du eine E-Mail, machst das auf und dann
hältst du das, was du da im Browser aufmachst,
einfach kurz hin. Da hältst du dann dein Telefon
auf so einem QR-Code.
Das ist echt klasse.
Was ich richtig angenehm finde an dem Wallet von
iOS zumindest, ist, dass der auch mit dem
knüpft sind. Und an dem Tag der
Reise zum Beispiel, hast du dann den ganzen Tag auf dem
Lockscreen dieses Ticket. Du musst das gerade
nur antippen bzw. drüber swipen und dann ist der QR-Code
direkt da und das Bild wird gleich hell.
Das heißt, du hast dann sehr einfach die Möglichkeit
und wenn du es gerade auf der Watch hast, das dann eben auch.
Und da habe ich auch tatsächlich auf dem Flug nach San Francisco gemacht,
dass das Luftfahrt-Ticket auf der
Watch gab, tippst es an, die Watch wird hell,
begeht nicht aus, wenn du den Arm wegdrehst und hältst einfach deinen Arm
auf den Scanner. Und ich war einer von quasi
10, 15 Leuten in der Schlange,
die ihre Apple Watch auf den Scanner
gehalten haben. Fühlt das richtig cool.
Das ist irgendwas, wo die Deutschen
ziemlich hinterher sind, oder?
Mir ist ja echt aufgefallen, als ich in London war
und mich da mit einer Freundin getroffen habe
und wir im Hyde Park auf so einem Festival einfach
irgendwie ein bisschen was essen wollten, da gab es ganz viel
Streetfood, da konntest du an irgendeinem
Pommesstand mit
hier Contactless Kreditkarte bezahlen.
Oder gar nicht mit Bitcoin oder so.
Die haben mich direkt komisch angeguckt, wenn du
mal Bargeld irgendwie rausgeholt hast.
Das ist so krass, die ganze Welt und Deutschland
im Vergleich, was Zahlungsmittel angeht.
Das ist ein riesiger Unterschied.
Aber Bitcoin ist eigentlich jetzt schon an einem Punkt,
wo du damit nicht mehr umgehen kannst, oder?
Ich habe noch so ein paar Restmünzen hier auf meinem Telefon gehabt.
Als ich das letzte Mal drauf geguckt hatte,
konnte ich mir da von Kinematik kaufen.
Und jetzt sind das irgendwie 12 Euro.
Und es ist immer noch weniger als die Network-Fee.
Also ich kann es, glaube ich,
immer noch nicht von meinem Gerät runter überweisen,
weil es weniger ist als die Network-Fee.
Du meinst jetzt die Transaktionsgebühren?
Genau.
Aber die sind doch nicht so hoch.
Die sind schon immer noch unerwartet hoch,
aber je nachdem, was du für eine Wallet-Client hast,
kannst du die natürlich auch selber einstellen
und so niedrig gehen, wie du möchtest.
Aber du hast halt Chancen,
das nimmt kein Miner, dass die mitnimmt.
Das ist natürlich immer der Fall.
Aber im Zweifelsfall,
wenn du es nicht gerade wirklich ohne Transaktionsgebühren reinstellst,
dann musst du halt einfach eine Weile warten.
Normalerweise geht das alles durch.
Also normalerweise, im schlimmsten Fall,
musst du also wirklich 24, 48 Stunden warten.
Irgendwo ist der Punkt,
wo das Netzwerk einfach deine Transaktion rejectet
und die einfach wieder löscht.
Aber eigentlich
passiert das weniger.
Die Network-Fee geht doch dann auch an denjenigen,
der es gemeint hat.
Deswegen sind meine auch daran interessiert, die Transaktion
mit den größten Gebühren eben
in ihren Block zu nehmen.
Weil sie halt wie
den größeren Reward ausgeführt hat.
Ich sah es neulich mit ein paar Leuten
am Tisch und die haben dann überhaupt keine Ahnung
von Bitcoin gehabt und mir Fragen gestellt.
Ich habe halt relativ wenig Ahnung von Bitcoin.
Ich habe dann gesagt, naja, du kriegst halt Geld, indem du signierst.
Das ist das Meinen, das habe ich dir erklärt.
Aber es gibt halt irgendwann einen Punkt, wo du nichts Neues mehr meinen kannst.
Da habe ich auch immer nichts gehabt.
Was ist denn dein Incentive, weiter zu signieren?
Du kriegst dann halt die Network-Phase.
Du irgendwann gibt es keine, also aktuell kriegst du ja mit jedem Block 12,5 Bitcoin geschenkt.
Das ist schon relativ viel.
Aber du musst halt auch eine immense Amount, diese Proof of Work zu berechnen, ist halt mittlerweile immens geworden.
Die Schwierigkeit dafür, die Komplexität.
Also das ist, finde ich, einfach wieder witzig an Bitcoin.
du rechnest ja wirklich bloß so lange an Hashes rum,
bis du, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Nullens
aktuell sind, die am Anfang
eine Schar 1-Hash dranhängen.
Das ist einfach
keine sinnvoll investierte
Rechenleiste.
Nee, also es ist auch wirklich,
ich habe jetzt keine Zahlen, aber es gibt Leute, die
schon sinnvoll dargestellt haben,
grafisch und in Zahlen,
dass eigentlich Bitcoin ganz schön schlecht für die Umwelt ist.
Wie war das?
Die Rechenleistung, die reinfließt,
Also wenn du es mal aufteilst, die Rechnungleistung für einen Block auf jede Transaktion,
dann kostet dich jede Transaktion ungefähr so viel Strom wie um neun Familienhaushalte einen Tag lang.
Jede Transaktion?
Ich dachte, jede...
Meine letzten ist ein Tweet in der Richtung lesend.
Ich habe die Zahlen nicht nachgeprüft.
Wie häufig wird signiert?
Also die Schwierigkeit wird angepasst, sodass alle zehn Minuten ein Block gemeint wird.
Dann ist wahrscheinlich jede Signatur, also alle zehn Minuten so ein Haushalt, oder?
Ich habe, wie gesagt,
ich müsste...
Die Network-Fee entspricht in etwa,
aber das ist jetzt alles haltwesend,
die Network-Fee entspricht in etwa dem,
was du für den Strom zahlen würdest.
Auch schön.
Oder andersrum, das war dann auch
bei der Ethereum-Vergleich,
dass das Ethereum-Netzwerk aktuell
mehr Strom verbraucht als Ecuador.
War das nicht auch so eine Sache?
Das ist alles hier ganz gefährlich.
Das heißt, du wirst nur noch eine Waage im Kopf haben.
Aber irgendwas in der Richtung war,
irgendein Ecuador-Vergleich mit Ethereum
oder wirklich? Ich glaube, ein oder zwei Ethereum.
Das wäre eigentlich witzig. Ethereum könnte man
eigentlich auch Ecuador-Coin nennen oder sowas.
Gab sich irgendein amerikanisches Land, die gerade
jetzt eine eigene Kryptowährung rausbringen,
um irgendwie mit Öl
verknüpft irgendein Bullshit?
Wie war das denn? Eigentlich habe ich
so viel Bullshit-Infos im Kopf,
aber ich hätte gar nicht mehr richtig... Das sind alles Sachen, die du
hinterher einfach in die Shownotes
schreiben wirst. Ach ja, das kommt in die Shownotes.
Links zu den beiden Tweets, wenn ich es finde.
Und diese Kryptowährung.
Genau. Schaut mal
jetzt auf euer Coverbild.
Wir werden jetzt sehen, dass nichts passiert ist, weil wir
nie daran denken, oh man war so ein Coverbild.
Ich glaube, einmal hatte ich einen Custom-Art drin, aber das
weiß ich nicht mehr, was das war.
Das müsste die letzte und die letzte Folge gewesen sein.
Die mal davor, die haben wir wieder vergessen.
Aber einmal war was.
So.
Da hat der Marco Arment, der Typ, der übrigens
der Typ, der Overcast
den iOS-Podcast
beklangt macht und den Podcast
ATP mit hostet,
der hat heute
gestern, vorgestern ein Tool
rausgebracht, um Podcasts zu offern.
Forecast heißt das Ganze.
Da gäbe ich das Namensschema.
Warum benutzen wir das noch nicht?
Ist ganz neu und ist minimal.
Ist eigentlich nur dafür da.
Was ich richtig schön kann, ist, es ist ein paralleler
MP3-Encode.
Ist das irgendwie eine
macOS? MacOS-App.
Du hast eine Podcast-Aufnahme und du machst damit
deine Chapter und am Ende
offerst du die MP3-Datei raus.
Und was der halt kann, weil er eben damit jetzt,
was die MP3-Spec wohl kann,
wusste ich gar nicht, aber kein Podcast-Player
kann, außer Overcast und
Forecast, das zu dem Entschrechen
einbauen, weil er jetzt quasi beide Seiten
davon hat, ist die Idee von Hidden Chapters,
wo es gar nicht so was existiert.
Das ist ein Chapter-Mark, der nicht
in der Table of Contents auftaucht,
aber den kannst du trotzdem nutzen, um
innerhalb von anderen Chapters, zum Beispiel Coverart, zu ändern.
Und somit ganz spezifisch an einer Stelle
die Grafik anzupassen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das geht, aber ich glaube, solche Sachen
werden doch bei diesen ganzen
es geht ja dann wahrscheinlich nicht nur bei MP3, oder?
Ich meine, die
unterstützen unterschiedlich, je nachdem
dieses Chapter-Prinzip. Das wäre mal noch so ein
interessantes Thema, was man irgendwie sich in der Zukunft
mal anlesen könnte für so einen Podcast.
Es gab ja,
früher haben wir jetzt, als wir alle nur
MP3 uns runtergeladen
oder selber kodiert haben, gab es ja
diese ID.3 Tag-Editoren,
wo das dann alles nachgerückt ist.
Und es gab irgendwie ID.3
V1 und V2 in unterschiedlichen
Version. Und im Endeffekt war das
irgendwie ein Format, was
in den Code,
in die MP3-Datei irgendwo mit reingeschrieben war
und eigentlich mit MP3 selber nichts zu tun hatte.
Du kannst es ja in andere Dateien
auch reinschreiben quasi.
Ich dachte, das war tatsächlich Teil der MP3-Spec,
dass da irgendwo am Anfang das passiert war.
Aber es gibt es halt auch für Ock.
Okay.
Mich würde jetzt mal interessieren, wie diese
ganzen anderen Formate. Bei Ock
konntest du halt plötzlich auch noch Chapter angeben,
den konntest du richtig reinschreiben.
Dann hattest zum Beispiel Fubar, oder wie hieß dieser andere Player?
Achso, Fubar, dieser Windows-Player, konnte dir das dann anzeigen, als wäre es eine Playlist gewesen.
Das war eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Das ist cool.
Und da konntest du dann, glaube ich, auch Bilder einbetten.
Mich würde mal interessieren, wie sich diese einzelnen Meta-Formate,
Meta-Daten-Formate für die einzelnen Medien-Daten unterhalten und was man verhalten
und wie sich die für Podcasts missbrauchen lassen.
Die Potlauf-Leute machen ja da auch relativ viel
Spezifikationen. Das war übrigens
ein witziges Detail von dem
Forecast, dessen Logo ist nämlich
ein F als deutsche Flagge,
weil der Wunsch
nach Chapter Marks, laut Marco Armin,
hauptsächlich aus Deutschland kommt und die
Deutschen sehr darauf beharren, dass Podcasts mit
guten Chapter Marks ausgestattet sind.
Es gab mal eine witzige
Folge, es gibt ja dieses
Twit Network
This Week in Tech von den
alten Screensavers-Leuten.
und die haben glaube ich
Lia Loport und die ganzen Leute drumherum,
da gibt es ja ein paar Sachen, die höre ich mir
manchmal auch noch als Podcast an.
Da gibt es einen, der heißt Floss Weekly.
Eigentlich
Floss im Sinne von FreeDB Open Source?
Ja. Und eigentlich ganz
cool, weil die halt jedes Mal irgendwie den Macher
von irgendeiner Open Source Software oder von irgendeiner Floss Software
interviewen, aber häufig haben die echt
überhaupt keine Ahnung, wovon die gerade reden,
wen sie gerade interviewen. Aber eine Folge
war mit Tim Britlove.
Ah, witzig.
Und da haben sie Tim Pridloff
über seine ganzen
Podlove-Projekte
interviewt, über seine
Initiative, die Podcast-
Software-Landschaft zu verbessern.
Das war ziemlich witzig, weil Tim Pridloff
ja quasi der deutsche
Leo Laporte ist.
Schöner Vergleich.
Ja, das war eigentlich
bloß so das. Aber
eine deutsche Flagge mit einem F.
Es sieht auch komisch aus, sieht mega weird aus.
Es ist auch ein bisschen noch ein Kreis drumherum.
Es fällt nicht ganz so hart auf, aber es sieht
schon sehr eigenartig aus.
Müssen wir uns mal angucken.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall der Witz daran.
Vielleicht können wir das ja mal ausprobieren.
Ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich mir einfach zu Weihnachten
ein anstiegiges Headset gönne.
Vielleicht gönnst du dir auch eins zu Weihnachten
und dann machen wir die Aufnahmen so.
Das wäre noch eine Idee. Mal schauen, ob noch
Raum für Weihnachtsgeschenke übrig ist.
Meine Eltern haben beschlossen,
bzw. ich habe beschlossen dieses Jahr nicht zu Weihnachten.
nach Hause zu fahren.
Ach so.
Und meine Eltern haben deswegen beschlossen,
dass sie mich letzte Woche, vorletzte Woche,
circa besucht haben.
Und wir die Bescherung einfach dementsprechend vorverlegt haben
auf Anfang Dezember.
Und ich habe zu Weihnachten von meinem Dad
oder zum Thema von meinen Eltern...
Ach so, du hast deine Weihnachtsgeschenke.
Ich habe mein Weihnachtsgeschenk schon.
Zum einen war es ein Lockpicking-Set
und es macht so viel Spaß.
Das ist cool.
Das ist so mega witzig.
Hast du auch ein paar Locks dazu gekriegt?
Ich habe, da waren zwei Schlösser tatsächlich dabei.
Hast du direkt deine Wohnungsschlüssel weggeworfen?
Nein.
Ich traue mich nicht,
an meiner Wohnungstür rumzufummeln,
aus zwei Gründen.
Zum einen habe ich Angst, dass ich es kaputt mache.
Und zum anderen habe ich Angst, dass ich es hinbekomme.
Und dann kann ich nicht mehr einschlägen.
Also das kann ich dir jetzt schon voraussagen,
dass du deine Wohnungstür relativ einfach aufkriegen kannst.
Aber da waren auch zumindest zwei Schlösser dabei,
die beide ultra cool sind.
Das eine ist so ein typisches Vorhängeschloss,
das andere ist so ein Türschloss.
Und die sind beide aus Innern.
Natürlich ein ordentliches Schloss aus Metall.
Aber der Schlosskörper ist durchsichtiges Plastik.
Das heißt, du siehst alles und kannst reinschauen.
Das ist mega cool zum Anschauen und zum Knacken.
Ja, unglaublich einfach und schnell.
Das ist ein schönes Nördgeschenk.
Super cool.
Das ist auf jeden Fall geil.
Ich muss zum Glück nicht so viele Leute beschenken.
Aber wir hatten uns jetzt neulich auf der Weihnachtsfeier,
da hatte jemand die Idee, da gab es so einen Adventskalender.
ohne dir so Postkarten oder Adventsglückwunschkarten abnehmen konntest.
Und da standen keine Glückwünsche drauf, sondern Wünsche.
Die haben irgendwie eine Partnerschaft mit irgendeiner Schule oder mit irgendeiner Kindertagesstätte.
Und da haben dann halt Kinder sich Wünsche drauf geschrieben.
Und die kannst du dir erfüllen?
Und die darfst du dir dann erfüllen.
Weil wir sind ja alles Mitarbeiter, die Geld verdienen.
Die können so einem Kind was schenken.
Wie oft denkt da Pony dran?
Und was ich mir gezogen habe,
da stand tatsächlich drauf,
hallo, ich bin so und so und ich bin
zehn Jahre alt und ich wünsche mir Minecraft-Figuren.
Die gibt es bei Müller für 10,99 Euro.
Stand da so drauf.
Da dachte ich mir, das ist ja nicht ganz cool.
In Minecraft gefühlt sehe ich die Dinger auch überall.
Nämlich,
bin ich heute...
Ich bin dann heute...
Ich arbeite
in der Innenstadt. Ich könnte jeden Tag gehen.
Am Samstag gehe ich los.
Das war absolut bekloppt.
Oh Gott, in der Vormeitagszeit am Samstag
in den Stadtfang.
Dann bin ich da zu Müller rein, die haben in so eine große Spielzeugabteilung
oben. Ich habe da eine Runde geguckt.
Nichts. Dann bin ich
irgendwie zu dieser
Spielexie, da bin ich eine Runde im Kreis gelaufen.
Nichts. Dann gab es noch einen anderen
Spielzeugladen. Da gab es Lego
Minecraft. Ich weiß, das war es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Und dann bin ich
noch in diesen Elfenwald
Nerd
Himmel Spielzeugladen gegangen.
Da gab es auch keine Minecraft
kurz am überlegen, ob ich die nicht bei Amazon bestelle.
Ich muss die
bis Ende nächster Woche
haben.
Und dann verpackt bei unserer Sekretärin
abgegeben.
Morgen ist verkauft auf einer Sonntag.
Vielleicht gehe ich morgen nochmal los.
Aber da werden sich die Leute
auf die Füße treten.
Auf jeden Fall.
Also Anfang, Mitte Dezember einkaufen
ist es schrecklich.
Ich habe mir extra
die Woche vor Weihnachten bereits Urlaub genommen.
vielleicht schon mal ein bisschen was hinzukriegen.
Aber das Weihnachtsgeschenk muss ich ja jetzt
wirklich diese Woche noch besorgen.
Sonst habe ich noch so ein paar andere Ideen, aber die sage ich
jetzt nicht on air.
Das könnten ja
Leute zuhören.
Du warst vor kurzem
im Süden unterwegs,
wovon du noch nicht viel erzählt hast.
Ah ja, ich war auf einem Kongress.
Das stimmt, das wollte ich ansprechen
im Zusammenhang mit Kongress.
Ah, wir waren noch auf Kongress, stimmt.
Ja, ich bin ja in meiner Firma als Typescript-Entwickler
und da habe ich mich auf den JS-Kongress schicken lassen,
noch mit zwei anderen Kollegen zusammen.
Das war ganz witzig, das war in München.
Wir haben uns sonntags einen Leihwagen abgeholt
und dann sind wir da hingedüst.
Das war ziemlich cool.
Ich habe mir vorher ein bisschen die Speaker angeguckt,
das war vornehmlich so Frontend-Zeugs.
Das war jetzt nicht so interessant.
Ich musste ja auch ein bisschen rechtfertigen,
warum du da hinfährst. Aber
im Hintergrund waren noch
so Death Rooms oder
wie nennt man das? Eine Un-Conference?
Ne, wie heißt das?
Das war nur, wo dann
unorganisierte Panels waren. Das heißt,
am Anfang irgendwie in so ein, da gab es
ein paar Nebenräume und in einem haben sie gesagt, so, ich würde
jetzt über das reden, ich würde jetzt über das reden, da haben Leute ihre
Themen oder ich würde gerne mit euch
diskutieren. Also so ein bisschen Lightning-Conference-mäßig.
Ja, das heißt glaube ich Un-Conference.
Ich glaube schon, es gibt schon, das ist bekannt vor.
Und da schreibst du das auf Zettel und dann gibt es irgendwie mehrere Tracks in fünf Räumen und dann haben die das...
So Barcamps da.
Ja, Barcamps, glaube ich, ist auch der Begriff dafür.
Und dann gab es relativ viele Leute, die über WebAssembly geredet haben.
Oh, cool.
Ja, es waren mehrere Entwickler von V8 da.
Es waren ein paar Leute, die bei Google an WebAssembly gearbeitet haben.
Google sitzt ja in München und macht eigentlich einen Großteil von V8 in München, interessanterweise.
Es waren relativ viele Leute von Mozilla da,
weil sie an dem Dienstag von der Konferenz
Firefox 57 veröffentlicht haben.
Und da war zum Beispiel Lynn Clark,
die auf hex.mozilla.org
diese geilen Strichmännchen-Blogposts macht.
Und hat einen Vortrag über
was alles in Firefox 57 technisch Neues gehalten.
Kann ich sehr gut empfehlen.
Das ist eine schöne Zusammenfassung auch von den Blogposts.
Also die Blogpost von Lynn Clark,
kommt in die Show Notes,
kann ich sehr empfehlen.
Es ist so ein bisschen XKCD-Style.
Manche von den Zeichnungen sind auch animiert.
Das ist die mit dem blauen Strick?
Genau.
Den duper schick.
Ja, super geil.
Und die hat halt auch dort einen Vortrag gehalten,
der das auch ziemlich gut zusammenfasst.
Der ist auch drei Tage später bereits auf YouTube gewesen.
Also würde ich mal verlinken, kann ich sehr empfehlen.
Ja, und da wurde ich halt so ein bisschen angesteckt
von WebAssembly, weil es irgendwie gefühlt auch so eine
WebAssembly-Rust-Konferenz war.
Es waren relativ viele Leute, die ich aus der Rust-Community kannte da.
Es war noch so ein bisschen...
Wie ist die Überschneidung für dieses
Venn-Diagram?
Ziemlich groß, oder?
Von dem Rust- und JS-Backend der Leute.
Naja, also für JS
war als Speaker
AG Dubstar.
Wenn Ashley Williams dann da ist, dann ist sie ja eh vorbei.
Ja, genau. Ashley Williams hat
eine Keynote gehalten und über
Node.js geredet und über WebAssembly.
Und die hat halt ihren Freund mit, das ist
Steve Klebnik, der in der Rust-Community
mitarbeitet. Aber sie macht ja auch ziemlich viel Rust.
die haben irgendwie NPM so, sie haben halt auch
bei NPM, oder? Genau. Und die haben doch irgendwie das Backend
von NPM, die performance-kritischen Dinge,
in Rust neu geschrieben.
Ja, ich weiß nicht genau, was sie gemacht haben, aber die haben
irgendwie, die migrieren jetzt von, haben einiges von
JavaScript auf Rust migriert.
Genau.
Dann waren noch ein, zwei
Leute aus der deutschsprachigen
Rust-Community da.
Jan-Erik hat einen Vortrag über
WebAssembly gehalten, hat am Anfang eine Demo
gemacht, wo keiner verstanden hat, was er uns da zeigen wollte
und auch nichts dazu gesagt hat und einfach
ein bisschen was gezeigt hat und dann weitergemacht hat.
Aber auf jeden Fall
ist das ein
ziemlich schickes Thema. Also es gibt ein paar
coole Libraries, zum Beispiel
std-web, um
Web-Anwendungen in Rust
zu schreiben. Was natürlich bescheuert ist,
aber es ist eigentlich
schon... Klingt super spannend.
Es klingt eigentlich super geil. Der Use Case ist
interessant. An manchen Stellen
fragt sich, wozu könnte ich das gebrauchen?
Was möchte
ich in Rust oder in nativen
schreiben. Erstmal soll ich kurz erzählen, was WebAssembly
überhaupt ist?
WebAssembly
ist quasi ein
Compile-Target für
ganz gewöhnliche Compiler, die normalerweise
C, C++, Rust, Go,
was ich kompilieren würde.
Und die kompilieren das dann nicht, du kompilierst dann nicht zu
also das kann zum Beispiel LLFM,
also jeder, der LLFM kompiliert werden kann,
kann nach WebAssembly kompilieren. Und was bei rausfällt,
ist nicht
x86-Assembly,
also Machine-Code, sondern WebAssembly.
Und das ist was, was dann der JIT-Compiler
deiner JavaScript-Engine im Browser ausführen kann.
I.O. ist dann relativ stark weggerappt.
Da hat das m-Skripten-Projekt schon relativ viel gemacht.
Also die haben eine ganze C-Library gerappt
und eine ganze SDL-Library in JavaScript gerappt.
Und wenn du dann in deinem C++-Code ein Printf machst,
dann wird das gemappt auf Standard-Out,
was in JavaScript dann von
Console-Log ersetzt wird.
Sehr witzig. Aber es hat wirklich den Effekt,
dass du Zeugs bauen kannst, was erstaunlich schnell läuft.
Und
die Möglichkeiten sind jetzt halt, dass du damit
Parser oder Krypto-Algorithmen
oder Bildbearbeitungsgeschichten...
Das ist erstaunlich beeindruckend, performante
3D-Spiele gesehen. Genau, also
erstaunlicherweise OpenGL-Zeugs
funktioniert relativ gut
und wird dann auf WebGL übersetzt.
Das ist beeindruckend. Was es noch nicht kann, ist,
das ist Multithreading.
Das soll aber 2018 kommen.
Also einer von diesen Barcamp-Vorträgen waren
die WebAssembly-Entwickler,
die bei Google arbeiten, die sagen,
ja, also Sachen, die wir demnächst vorhaben, sind zum Beispiel
Multithreading. Wie machen sie Multithreading?
Naja,
es ist halt alles von JavaScript
gehostet. Und in JavaScript gibt es WebWorker,
wo du mehrere
Threads in JavaScript aufmachen kannst.
Und die werden dann für Multithreading
in deinem WebSystem.
Da ist so eine GGS-Ebene überall drunter.
Ich dachte explizit nicht mehr.
ähm, doch
also es wird dann, der JIT-Compiler
macht es halt dann zu quasi nativem Code
aber die API drumrum
ist komplett JavaScript
also du kriegst einen Blob
das ist so ein WebAssembly
Blob, den du dann mit
also ich hab damit rumgespielt
und es ausprobiert, das ist noch nicht
an einem Punkt, wo es wirklich ohne weiteres
verwendbar ist
ähm, zum Beispiel kannst du nicht einfach
in deinem HTML sagen, hier lade mal dieses
WebAssembly-Script, so wie du JavaScript lernen würdest,
wo du deine URL angibst, sondern du
musst ein weiteres Skript schreiben, was das dann fetcht
und in so ein WebAssembly
ausführt. Also es ist alles noch nicht
geil. Aber
ein paar Use-Cases wären schon ganz
spannend dafür. Vor allem
interessanterweise könntest du
bei Node.js drauf verzichten,
native Add-ons für
deine Node-Anwendung über
die sich ständig ändernde V8-API
oder über die
über diese
Native Abstractions von Node
oder über die neue Node-API
zu rappen, sondern du machst
das einfach,
kopierst das einfach nach Resim und führst das dann in Node.js
aus. Also du kannst jetzt
nativen Code bei Node.js von unten und von
unten.
Ich kann Hendricks Handbewegung sehen, soll lieber wunderschön
dieses von unten und von oben
klanschen. Bist aber auch einfach
zu beeindrucken.
Ja, das war zumindest ziemlich
spannend. Vor allem, dass
so viele Leute aus beiden Communities
da waren. Der witzigste Moment war eigentlich,
als einer in einem von diesen
Death Rooms
von, ich glaube,
Daniel Ehrenberg eingeladen
wurde. Der Name klingt bloß deutsch,
der ist eigentlich Amerikaner. Der ist
Mitglied des TC39, das ist dieses
JavaScript-Standidisierungs-
Gremium.
Und da bin ich mit meinen Kollegen reingegangen
und da ging es einfach,
TC39 Standardization Process,
how can we do things better?
Und im Endeffekt stand er vorne
und ich und meine beiden Kollegen
und noch ein Typ
und ein Typ von Google, das war's.
Und der so, ja, also wir
kriegen so ein bisschen wenig Feedback, es gibt so Proposals
auf GitHub, die haben ja mittlerweile ihre Proposals
auch alle auf GitHub für die neuen JavaScript Features.
Und irgendwie kriegen wir nicht so richtig Feedback
und wir würden gerne die Community ein bisschen besser involvieren.
Und das,
wie geht's denn euch so?
Und meine beiden Kollegen so
und ich so
und der
andere ist still und der Typ von Google
guckt auf sein Handy und
nach ein paar Sekunden
Stille sag ich, naja, ich weiß jetzt nicht genau,
wie es bei euch abläuft. Ich finde eigentlich den Prozess
bei Rust ganz cool.
Ah, was machen die denn? Die haben diesen
RFC-Prozess und das ist alles auf GitHub
und es wird so miteinander diskutiert und es gibt
so Core-Teams. Aber so richtig genau erzählen
kann ich es nicht.
Aber Steve Kleppeneck ist im Westen gekommen.
vielleicht kann dir der mir erzählen, achso,
dann gehe ich mal rüber.
Da ist er rübergegangen,
Steve saß gerade irgendwie an seinem Laptop und hat irgendwie
gerade ein bisschen E-Mails gelesen und, sag mal, wir machen
ja gerade so ein Panel, kannst du mal rüberkommen?
Dann hat er den rübergeholt und dann im Endeffekt
war es dann plötzlich so, dass Steve in seinen
Vortragsmodus verfallen ist, dann stand er plötzlich vorne
und hat irgendwie eine halbe Stunde über den RFC-Prozess
von Rust geredet und der
Daniel von
DC39 hat dann ab und zu mal
Fragen gestellt, wie das so
funktioniert und wow, wie total
witzig. Also Leute
miteinander verbunden.
Schau mal, der sitzt eben an, bring mal
Röberstein-Röber. Ja, ich liebe
Konferenzen, das ist total geil.
Auf jeden Fall.
Da waren auch Leute
von, ich weiß gar nicht, ich hab den Namen vergessen,
einer von Microsoft da, der
Editor von,
Editor des TC39,
also nochmal TC39 ist das Standardisierungsgremium
von ECMA,
oder nicht, ich weiß gar nicht,
welche Rolle die konkret haben, aber die sind die,
die die neuen Vorschläge für
den nächsten ECMAScript-Standard
kuratieren.
Und der Editor von dieser
Gruppe war auch da, der arbeitet bei Microsoft
an deren JavaScript
Engine,
Chuck Rackour,
und der arbeitet auch an TypeScript,
witzigerweise. Das heißt, der sitzt so
an mehreren Stellen, das ist ganz witzig,
der hat ein bisschen Vortrag für TypeScript gehalten
und er hat auch gemeint, naja, also
einer der ersten Schritte, die ich gemacht habe,
als ich die Aufgabe des Editors
für TC39 übernommen habe, war,
dass ich dieses Word-Dokument,
was seit 1995
traditionell weitergepflegt
wurde, mit Anmerkungen,
dass ich das erstmal umgewandelt
habe nach Markdown
und jetzt haben wir das alles auf GitHub. Also ich kann nur
empfehlen, geht mal auf GitHub,
github.com slash TC39 slash
proposals, da sind so die nächsten Sachen, die in JavaScript
landen sollen, schon mal
als mit Draft
oder Suggestion Status.
Das sind ein paar
schöne Sprachfeatures, auf die ich auch sehr erwarte bei dieser
Sprache. Cool, irgendwas Spontanes,
was dir da direkt eintritt? Ja, sowas wie
Null-Coalescing-Operator, also dieser
Fragezeichen-Operator, den Ruby
und CoffeeScript zum Beispiel hatten,
dass du
auf Properties von Objekten
und unter Properties von Objekten zugreifen kannst,
auch wenn die Parents potenziell
undefined sind. Das ist eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Ist das das selber als der Null-Coalescing?
In Swift sind das explizit zwei unterschiedliche
Konzepte.
Das sind auch da zwei unterschiedliche
Es gibt zwei Stellen, an denen
das Fragezeichen verwendet werden kann.
Okay.
Das ist der schöne Name in Swift.
Also das eine ist quasi Fragezeichen
und das andere ist Fragezeichen Punkt.
Ah, okay. In Swift ist es Fragezeichen
und Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen.
Und der Fragezeichen-Operator,
also zum Beispiel, du gehst auf Unterproperties, Unterproperties
oder Method Calls von irgendwas, was irgendwo in der
Chain optional ist. Diese Optional Chaining-Sache,
den wird liebevoll der Call-Me-Maybe-Operator
genannt.
Und was ich super schön finde,
der Null-Corelessing-Operator,
beziehungsweise wahrscheinlich der Null-Corelessing,
der in C-Sharp existiert,
weil das da Fragezeichen-Doppelpunkt ist.
Wenn du auf die Seite wie ein Emoji packst,
sieht das aus wie
zwei Augen mit einer Elvis-Docke.
Deswegen wird das auch der Elvis-Operator.
Genau, genau. Also hier heißt er
Knowledge Coalescing
Operator.
Genau.
Und dann gibt es noch,
was ich auch schön finde, ist,
ich finde es gerade nicht,
aber es steht ja auch immer auf dieser Seite,
diese Pipelining-Syntax für Function Cores,
doch der Pipeline Operator,
den man
eventuell aus
aus
Elixir kennt oder aus anderen
funktionalen Sprachen, wo da
ein Pipe und ein
größer als Zeichen hast.
Damit du nicht Funktionsaufrufe,
die du chainedst, die sich ineinander packen,
rückwärts schreiben musst und immer das in die
Klammer reinschreiben musst oder die Zwischenwerte,
so kannst du die Aufrufe hintereinander schreiben
und pipest quasi von
einem ins nächste rein. Das ist eigentlich ein geiles Feature von
Bash, dass man da
den Output von einem Programm ins nächste reinpipen
kann und irgendwie
hat es kaum eine Sprache gehabt.
Einen Film kannst du tatsächlich auch gut selber
bauen, aber das ist halt nie
Man sieht es selten als Standard.
Und Elixir hat das halt wirklich, das ist so der Weg in Elixir.
Und das ist auch super schick gelöst, finde ich.
Das ist echt lesbar.
C++ soll das bekommen.
Ach so.
Und zwar arbeiten die ja schon seit Ewigkeiten an diesem Ranges-Proposal.
Was namentlich so ein bisschen komisch ist,
aber Ranges sind quasi in C++.
Da hast du Iteratoren, die Pointer auf das Erste
und auf hinter dem letzten Element einer Menge sind.
Immer Punkt Beginn und Punkt End.
Methode. Und alles, was das implementiert,
ist quasi eine Range.
Und dann baut
Eric Niebler, heißt der, glaube ich,
das ist, glaube ich, schon die dritte Iteration von
einem Proposal. Der ist richtig von dem C++
Standardgremium auch angestellt.
Was irgendwann vielleicht in C++
35 landet. Keine Ahnung.
Ist da nicht gerade eine neue Version
rausgekommen? 17 ist jetzt schon
analysiert, da ist es nicht drin. Ach so. Es braucht
Concepts. Concepts sind
das, was in C++ oder was in
Rust Trades wären. Ich liebe, dass das C++
quasi alles hat an Features von anderen Sprachen,
aber immer unter einem anderen Namen.
Das muss man nie drüber reden können.
Und nie mit einem Sane Default, sondern falsch rum.
Aber die haben es zum Beispiel einfach gemacht,
also da hast du deine
Range,
irgendeine Liste und dann, die haben
den BitShift, den Bit
oder Operator, also ein einzelnes
Pipe dafür überladen.
Dann kannst du das nach Map
und das dann nach Sort und das dann nach Filter
pipen. Das ist aber eigentlich ganz cool.
Das sieht auch aus wie Bash quasi.
Das sieht auch noch aus wie ein Bash.
Das ist doch cool.
Da kann man es verstehen, wie man es liest.
Eine Sache, die noch war, es war
ein Dev Room, wo er auch nochmal über diese Proposals
geredet hat, auch die Daniel Erdenberg.
Und dieses Pipeline Operator
Proposal ist auch von ihm.
Und da hat sich dann
plötzlich die Frage gestellt, was ist denn mit
Async Await an der Stelle?
Da pipest du also von Methode,
ich hatte so ein Beispiel,
ich habe einen String, der heißt Hello
und den pipe ich nach Methode Doublesay,
dann sagt er das irgendwie zweimal und dann pipe ich das nach
capitalize, und dann
habe ich das nach exclaim, was einfach
in Anführungsstrichen,
Ausrufezeichen hinten dran hängt.
Was ist, wenn eine von den Methoden jetzt
async ist?
Du musst ja irgendwo await reinschreiben.
Und dann hat er irgendwie in diesem Beispiel
Doc, was man sich auch auf GitHub angucken kann,
hat er dann geschrieben, naja, sagen wir mal
capitalize, das wird jetzt ein bisschen schwierig nachzuvollziehen
eventuell, capitalize ist
jetzt async. Da schreibe ich also rein
hello und dann
pipe double save, pipe
Await, Pipe
Capitalize, Pipe
Explain. Das Await ist
alleine zwischen Pipe? Das wäre
so ein Proposal gewesen.
Man könnte das auch, und da hat er gesagt,
wir sind uns natürlich ganz sicher, man könnte das auch auf die gleiche
Zeile schreiben, gebt uns doch mal Feedback.
Das finde ich eigentlich cool, dass du so, du konntest halt so ein bisschen
bike-shatten über Sprachfeatures mit den Leuten,
die halt die nächsten Sprachfeatures
standardisieren werden.
Und irgendeiner hat gesagt, naja, der Aufruf
ist ja hier rückwärts. Wenn ich das
Funktion in Funktion
ineinander schachteln würde, so wie jetzt.
Da würde ich ja schreiben,
exclaim auf
capitalize auf
double say auf
hello rückwärts. Und so drehst du die
Reihenfolge um. Da müsste ja das
await hinter dem
capitalize stehen. Hat er gemeint,
ja stimmt. Und hat es direkt in diesem Dokument geändert.
Und ich dachte so, nein!
Auf keinen Fall!
Du kommst dann schlichter
Scherz.
Das ist ja überhaupt gar nicht mehr lesbar.
Wobei es ist schön, darüber zu reden und mit den Leuten zu diskutieren.
Auf jeden Fall.
Das ist ein sinnvolles Bike-Shedding.
Ja, Bike-Shedding ergibt vollkommen Sinn.
Du darfst zahlflos nicht mit dann machen.
Also das Problem an Bike-Shedding über Sprachen ist,
du darfst es nicht dann machen,
wenn du eigentlich Sachen mit dieser Sprache machen sollst.
Das Problem ist, dass du eine Abstraktionsebene zu weit oben bist.
Schön, das stimmt.
Und deswegen
hat ein Team bei mir in der Firma
extra Bikeshitting-Meeting
einmal die Woche. Da bin ich auch schon mal zu eingeladen worden.
Ich habe ein Meeting mit einem Kollegen, der sitzt in Santa Barbara.
Und der hat dann auch mal gesagt,
das ist jetzt so ein Thema, da können wir mal,
wir brechen das dann immer
ab und sagen, da sprechen wir bei unserem Bikeshitting-Meeting
drüber. Und dann haben sie mich zu einem Bikeshitting-Meeting
eingeladen, weil das war dann leider 23
Uhr deutscher Zeit.
Das war sehr witzig.
Ist ja auch ein Jagdshaving-Tag.
Das mache ich eh die ganze Zeit.
Das Witzige ist,
den Begriff Bikeshaving musste ich auch meinen Kollegen
erst erklären.
Und mit Yakshaving brauche ich glaube ich gar nicht erst anfangen.
Also ich glaube, das Problem
bei Yakshaving ist, da bin ich mir immer noch nicht ganz sicher,
ob das wirklich das meint, von was ich denke,
dass es das meint.
Erklär mir mal Yakshaving.
Jetzt weiß ich, dass ich
ganz sicher Brutschüttel habe, deswegen werde ich es doch
lieber vorher googeln.
Also laut
An apparently useless activity,
which by allowing you to overcome intermediate
difficulties allows you to solve a larger problem.
Also
für mich ist...
Was sinnlos erscheint, was du tust, aber
während du es tust, kannst du anscheinend
ein größeres Problem lösen.
Also ich kann...
Ich habe mir das immer so vorgestellt, ich muss jetzt
hier
Problem XY lösen, aber
um es wirklich lösen zu können,
es liegt mir halt noch
ein anderes Problem im Weg, was damit direkt
erstmal nichts zu tun hat, was mich allerdings behindert
und was umfangreich ist. Diese Merke mit der
Mittelfolge, wo Brian Cranston immer
ein anderes, tieferes Problem findet. Genau,
also er kommt nach Hause und ist einfach
die Glühbirne kaputt und dann geht er an den Schrank,
um die Glühbirne rauszuholen, merkt, dass die
Tür knarzt, dann
sucht er eine Schraubenzieher, den Schraubenzieher findet er nicht,
dann merkt er, dass die Schublade klemmt, wo der Schraubenzieher drin wäre,
dann möchte er
Öl drauf, möchte er die Schublade
ölen, dann merkt er, dass das Öl alle ist
und
will er sich neues Öl holen und dann siehst du
einen Schnitt, wie seine Frau ein paar Stunden später nach Hause kommt
und er unter dem Auto liegt und es auch so zu sagen.
Also das ist Yuckshaving, oder?
Die zweite Deutung passt ein bisschen
besser, glaube ich noch.
A less useful activity done consciously or subconsciously
to procrastinate about a larger but more useful task.
Und das trifft, glaube ich, ganz gut.
Ich glaube, das ist das, was ich den ganzen Tag mache.
Man sucht sich seine Probleme zusammen.
Naja, es ist ja ein bisschen gefährlich,
ist ja zum Beispiel,
wie sorgt man dafür, dass seine Software ordentlich
bleibt und maintainbar bleibt.
Also ich könnte jetzt, wenn ich ein neues Feature einbaue,
könnte ich das, und ich merke, dass meine Software das nicht wirklich unterstützt,
oder meine Architektur das momentan nicht wirklich gut unterstützt,
dann könnte ich das da irgendwie reinhacken und es dann irgendwie eklig ankriegen,
aber dann akkumuliert sich halt so...
Technical Dead.
...so Ekelcode.
Ja, genau.
Ich könnte mich aber auch erst mal zwei Stunden hinsetzen und die Codebase so refactoren,
dass das, was ich hinterher machen will, einfach geht.
Es gibt keinen goldenen Standard,
was der beste Weg ist, aber du willst
irgendwo natürlich das Ganze ein bisschen sauber halten.
Und das musst du irgendwann machen. Wenn du das nicht tust
und wirklich diese Akkumulation
an Ekelcode immer weiterführst, dann hast du
irgendwann eine wirklich unmaintainbare Codebase.
Ja, also irgendwann hast du, das gibt es ja auch häufig,
die Leute sagen sich jetzt,
ich bin ja nicht dafür da, diesen Code
hier aufzuräumen, ich bin ja bloß angestellt,
um dieses Feature einzubauen, was ich gerade einbauen
soll. Also hacke ich das da jetzt irgendwann
rein. Und dann hast du halt eine Codebase, die ist
irgendwann fünf Jahre alt und der hilft dann nur noch
Feuer.
Rewrite!
Nee, klar, so ist passiert. Das ist
technical debt. Du musst die irgendwann
abbezahlen. Genau.
You have to pay it at some point.
Und am liebsten zumindest einen Teil davon
direkt. Damit es gar nicht erst so ein
großer Berg wird.
Zumindest ein Teil.
Es geht halt auch nicht immer. Du kannst nicht
direkt immer alles refactoren, direkt
um selbst den kleinsten Scheiß
einzubauen. Das geht nicht.
aber du musst irgendwo einen goldenen Mittelweg finden.
Ich habe so ein Projekt
auf Arbeit, der brauche ich
an so einem Code-Generator
und der soll
einmal für JavaScript
und einmal für C++ Code generieren
und da sieht es dann
meistens so aus, ich soll
ein neues Feature in den generierten Code einbauen,
also der generierte Code soll ein neues Feature
unterstützen und
ich fange an, das zu coden,
generierst halt Code, der Code generiert,
der Code generiert irgendwann, du merkst halt,
dass du mit der internen Struktur von deinem Code-Generator
das, was du jetzt eigentlich hinschreiben würdest,
normalerweise einfach hinschreiben würdest,
gar nicht richtig ausdrücken kannst.
Und dann, ja, ich möchte jetzt hier plötzlich auf das zugreifen,
oh, an der Stelle in meinem Code-Generator,
wenn ich über meine interne Repräsentation von meinem Code,
von meiner Datenstruktur rübergehe,
habe ich dieses Wissen gerade gar nicht.
Weiß ich gar nicht, wie ich das hinschreiben soll.
Dann machst du halt genauso.
Dann habe ich teilweise
Commits gemacht
an die Codebase,
die zum Schluss im generierten
Code drei Zeilen geändert haben,
wo ich die gesamte Code-Generator-Infrastruktur
relativ stark ändern musste.
Das ist dann, denke ich mir auch,
das ist Jackshaving.
Ja, muss halt teilweise auch sein.
Wenn die Architektur das nicht hergibt,
dann muss sie das halt
dementsprechend angepasst werden.
Und wenn es im Endresultat keinen sichtbaren Unterschied macht,
dann ist das auch nicht schlimm.
genau. Kannst auch
eine komplette, keine Ahnung,
irgendwelche User-Phasing-Software
komplett neu schreiben, komplett
so basteln, dass die halt für den Endnutzer
überhaupt nicht anders tut,
aber komplett anders
interne Struktur hat und viel besser läuft
oder schlechter oder keine Ahnung. Ich möchte fast behaupten,
das ist der Hauptgrund, warum sie Firefox 57
ein neues Theme gegeben hat.
Ja, ich kann mir echt gut vorstellen, habe mir auch schon gedacht,
dass es halt sonst kein Unterschied wäre
und es fühlt sich halt einfach nicht besser an,
weil es gleich ausschaut, nur ein bisschen
obwohl intern sich so viel geändert hat.
Hast du nicht irgendwie...
Das hat Vincent erzählt im Halo Swift-Cast,
wie viel
prozentual, wie viel sich geändert hatte,
wie viele Millionen Zeilen angefasst wurden
von den paar Millionen Zeilen, die da in der
Co-Page sind. Meinst du das bei Firefox?
Ja, 8 Millionen Zeilen Code oder sowas.
Von wie viel hast du das?
Naja, die haben quasi die gesamten Komponenten,
die sie in Rust erst jetzt haben, auf einen Schlag...
Das ist halt schon echt
viel passiert intern.
Richtig, richtig viel.
Eigentlich könnten wir jetzt mal
Henrik Skopin
grüßen, der mit mir zusammen
das Rust-Meetup
in Dresden organisiert. Der hatte halt beim letzten
Meetup einen relativ guten Vortrag über
Firefox 57 gehalten.
Und darum ist da sehr viel interner eingegangen,
die sie geändert haben.
Oder war es in der Pre-Show?
Ich glaube, wir haben nie...
Wir haben einfach auch mal gesagt,
wir nehmen das mal auf.
Vielleicht haben wir das schon erzählt.
Keine Ahnung.
Oder haben wir das auf dem Weg hierher?
Zumindest,
der neue Firefox ist ziemlich krass.
Ich fand es ziemlich cool, auf dem JS-Kongress
zu sein
und dort zu sitzen
im Publikum, während
Lynn Clark darüber erzählt,
was jetzt im neuen Firefox drin ist, an dem Tag,
als diese Version veröffentlicht wurde.
Und ich saß zufälligerweise
in der gleichen
Reihe im Publikum wie
Mitchell Baker. Wer ist das?
Das ist quasi die Chefin von Mozilla.
Witzig.
Dementsprechend, also es waren relativ
viele Museums da, das war ziemlich cool.
Das glaube ich gern.
Apropos der JS-Kongress, lassen wir nochmal kurz zum
Congress zurückkommen, zum Upcoming 34
C3, den wir vorhin mal kurz angesprochen hatten.
Ja.
Bist du gespannt?
Auf jeden Fall.
Auf jeden Fall. Also hast du schon
irgendwie eine Übernachtungsmöglichkeit
dafür?
An wenig Zusammenzimmer?
Nee.
Aber weiß ich nicht mehr, wer in dem Zimmer drin war.
Ich habe ein paar Leute in ein Zimmer genommen.
So im Hostelzimmer.
Aber dass Leipzig ist und leider direkt nach Weihnachten
auch niemand auf die Katzen hier aufpackt,
werden meine Freundin und ich, die beide zum Kongress fahren,
wohl regelmäßig mal nach Hause fahren, um Katzen zu füttern.
Aber das ist ja nicht so der Aufwand.
Ab und zu mal das Fenster aufmachen, dass sie nicht ersticken.
Ja, genau.
Leipzig ist praktischerweise,
ist ja wirklich von Dresden jetzt nicht wirklich weit weg,
eine kostenlose Zugfahrt für Studenten.
Meine Eltern wohnen noch näher an Leipzig
als Dresden. Dementsprechend werde ich einfach
meine Allys nach Weihnachten, also die ich
ja über Weihnachten besuche, dann werde ich
einfach, glaube ich, von dort aus jeden Tag pendeln.
Das ist eine Dreiviertelstunde mit dem Auto.
Das ist ja super easy. Auf jeden Fall. Also ich werde
dann jeden Tag dort irgendwie
nachts um drei mit dem Auto wieder zu meinen Eltern fahren.
Voll cool. Nice.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich habe auch schon ein Assembly angemeldet.
Ah. Aber es gibt keine Rust Assembly.
Doch. Das habe ich angemeldet.
Da muss ich mal noch
ein paar Leute
von den Berlinern
schreiben, dass die mir nochmal neue Sticker zuschicken
und dann wollte ich noch so ein Poster drucken.
Ich habe überlegt, die letzten Male habe ich das Poster gedruckt
und das irgendwie
das vorletzte Mal
an die Wand gehängt, weil wir eine Wand hatten
und letztes Mal hatten wir
mitten im Raum und da haben wir
dann irgendwie so einen Stuhl
das fand ich alles irgendwie ein bisschen heckisch, also da muss ich mir
dieses Jahr mal noch was überlegen, ansonsten habe ich
So sind Standarte.
Man kann sich ja bei
solchen Druckfirmen
kann man sich auch solche Aufstellflaggen,
die ja so...
Das stimmt, ja.
Erstens wird das teuer und zweitens sehen wir dann aus wie so ein
Marketing-Scheiß und das sind wir eigentlich
nicht. Also das ist so ein bisschen gehackt aus.
Da war jeder ein Rust-Umhang,
der an dem Tür sitzt.
Ein Rust-Umhang? Ja, so eine klassische Superman-Cape.
Du hast sowas oder warum stehst du gerade auf?
Nee, ich möchte dir was zeigen, was ich von Henrik geschenkt bekommen habe.
Das ist ja für die Hörer nichts, aber
das hat er mir beim letzten Meetup mitgebracht.
Ich beschreibe es mal kurz.
Das ist mit einer CNC-Fräse
aus so einem Stück
dunklem durchsichtigen Kunststoff
ausgelasertes
Rust-Logo.
Ich verspreche es mal nicht zu viel, aber ich mache mal ein Foto
davon und schaue mal, ob ich das
als Coverart jetzt gerade...
Das hat er mir als Dankeschön mitgebracht
dafür, dass ich ihm vom Rust-Fest
so eine Plüschkrabbe
missgebracht habe. Super schick.
Auf jeden Fall.
Das hat bei mir einen Ehrenplatz hier in meiner
kleinen Büroecke.
Hast du das Hafnarb schon ausgefüllt?
Ja, ich habe es zumindest ein bisschen
durchgeguckt und
dann habe ich es vergessen und
dann war es plötzlich schon entschieden, glaube ich.
Du warst so nicht durch.
Für die Unitiierten
das Hafnarb
ein Dings.
Hafnarb ist Hauptplan rückwärts.
Ach nee, nicht rückwärts.
Klar.
Hafnarb.
Vielleicht hörte ich noch eine P auf.
Das ist einfach durchgewurschtelt.
Wie nennt man das nochmal?
Ein Anagramm.
Ein Anagramm, das war das Wort,
ich suchte, danke.
Für Fahrplan, genau.
Um die zu entscheiden.
Also es ist ein tolles Tool,
sehr funktional,
nicht sehr schick,
aber super funktional,
wo alle angemeldeten Talks drinstehen
und Leute können eben dann abstimmen,
was sie interessant,
also nicht wertend,
aber was man interessant findet
und gerne hören möchte
und dann wird automatisch geplant,
sodass es möglichst wenig Konflikte gibt
für die Talks, die die meisten Leute
hören möchten. Und so hat man
auch gleich einen Überblick, was es alles Cooles gibt.
Sehr empfehlend, hoffe ich. Ich weiß noch nicht genau,
aber ich gehe mal davon aus. Mein Cousin
hält wieder einen Talk. Dein Cousin hält einen Talk?
Mein Cousin hält wieder einen Talk. Wie, was heißt wieder?
Hat der schon einen Talk? Der hat vor drei Jahren,
als ich nicht da war, einen Talk gehalten. Über was?
Er ist der Mitbegründer
vom Zentrum für politische Schönheit. Ach echt?
Und er hält
dieses Mal wieder einen Talk. Die haben ja gerade ihre aktuelle
Aktion gemacht. Deine Stähle.
Ist der da bei den ganzen Interviews gewesen?
Der Philipp Ruch, genau.
Ach so.
Das ist mein Cousin.
Die Aktion fand ich super geil.
Unglaublich cool, oder?
Mal eine kurze Zusammenfassung.
Es gibt die AfD.
Das ist ein bisschen weit gefasst jetzt.
Das Zentrum für politische Schönheit
macht krasse Kunstaktionen
im linken Spektrum auf eine Art und Weise,
dass selbst den Linken teilweise
zu links sind.
Und wollen damit auch
denjenigen, die politischen Aktivismus in der
Richtung machen, so ein bisschen ein Spiegelverhalten,
dass man es noch krasser machen kann.
Und dass man überhaupt Dinge machen kann
und bewirken kann und nicht einfach nur, keine Ahnung,
ein bisschen Likes auf Facebook.
Genau. Und was sie gemacht haben,
ist, dass sie dem
Bernd Höcke von der AfD
...
Bernd Höcke hat
vor ein paar Monaten in Dresden einen Vortrag
gehalten und dabei
das Holocaust-Mahnmal
in Berlin
als Mahnmal der Schande bezeichnet.
Irgendwie ist sie auch eine Schande,
derer da gedacht wird, eine historische Schande.
Aber auf die Art und Weise,
die er ausgedrückt hat, war halt sehr herablassend.
Und er hat da ausgedrückt,
dass man sich nicht schämen sollte.
Und das
hat sehr rausgehängt,
dass er eigentlich lieber
Geschichtsrevisionismus betreiben würde.
Und
deshalb hat das
Zentrum für politische Schönheit
in seinem
Heimatort, das Nachbargrundstück zu seinem Haus angemietet.
Genau.
Und ich weiß gar nicht, haben die das in einer Nacht- und Nebelaktion gemacht?
Das muss ewig gedauert haben.
Die haben ihm dann eine kleine Kopie des Holocaust-Mahnmals in sein Nachbargrundstück gestellt.
Erstmal hat es mit damit angefangen, dass sie, also die Aktion könnt ihr nachlesen auf
deinem-stele.de.
Erstmal hat es damit angefangen, dass sie ihn ein paar Monate lang observiert haben.
Das müssen sie quasi gemacht haben, bevor sie sich entschieden haben, diese Stele zu bauen,
oder?
Ja, das war schon gut.
Also ich glaube, das war schon länger geplant, was genau passiert.
aber die Aktion läuft schon ein paar Monate.
Aber dass sie ihn observiert, also ich hätte
die Aktion persönlich auch wirklich geiler
gefunden, wenn sie nur so ein Mahnmal
gebaut hätten. Diese Observiererei
hat es irgendwie dann schon wieder so ein bisschen
fishy gemacht. Naja, es geht halt mit in die
Richtung, dass den Verfassungsschutz
wir haben es den zivilrechtlichen
Verfassungsschutz, haben es glaube ich genannt,
getründet. Ja, quasi
in Opposition zu diesem Thüringer
Heimatschutz, der so ein Naziverein ist.
Oder dem Verfassungsschutz, der ja so ein Naziverein
ist.
Genau.
Und halt dazu ein bisschen Konkurrenz machen
und die andere Seite observieren.
Und das ging dann halt wunderschön über in diese Deine-Stähler-Aktion,
wo man ein bisschen Geld spenden konnte,
was dann sehr schnell zusammen war.
Und dann war das Mahnmal schon hingebaut.
Und das Holocaust-Mahnmal eben quasi direkt vor die Tür gebaut
mit dem Angebot, wenn er davor, wie Willy Brandt,
auf die Knie geht und um Vergebung bittet,
dann sei ihm verzeihen für das, was er gesagt hat.
Aber das Angebot war schnell wieder vom Tisch.
Und mittlerweile läuft auch gut rechtlich was.
aber was ich auch sehr krass beeindruckend fand.
Also er hat sie dann, glaube ich, als Terroristen
bezeichnet, was aufgrund dieser
für die Aktion
natürlich auch überhaupt nicht angemessen ist.
Ich finde es auch krass, wie viele
Morddrohungen beim ZPS dafür eingingen.
Das ist ja...
Ach was, dieser Typ, den sie
bei Logbuch Netzpolitik abgespielt haben,
der von der
Totenkopfabteilung der AfD
war oder sowas.
Da weiß ich gar nicht, was du meinst.
Also es gab ein paar Aufzeichnungen von dem
Anruf beantwortet. Den werden sie wahrscheinlich beim
Kongress abspielen. Da hat
irgendeiner so einen
Nazi-Hool angerufen, der irgendwie gemeint hat,
der ist von der Totenkopfstandarte der AfD.
Sie möchten quasi
die SA der AfD sein.
Und
konnte sich nicht wirklich
ausdrücken, war aber
sehr hasserfüllt und hat dem irgendwie
auch mit dem Tod getraut.
Wo sind diese Vollidioten? Ich meine,
ich möchte es gar nicht wissen, aber warum gibt es
solche Menschen?
Tja, also wir sollten uns gesellschaftliche Fragen stellen,
wie wir in einer Gesellschaft leben können,
wo aufgeklärte Menschen sowas nicht mitbekommen,
dass es Leute gibt, die solche Meinungen entwickeln.
Das ist unglaublich.
Die Leute waren schon immer da,
die kommen ja nicht aus dem Nichts,
die haben bloß plötzlich eine Basis,
wo sie sich kristallisieren und sammeln können,
sodass wir es plötzlich merken,
dass es Leute gibt, die bei Pegida mitlaufen würden
und es tun.
Die gab es auch schon vor 10 Jahren, diese Leute.
Krassere Meinung als das haben wir.
Genau.
Aber gut, zurück zum Kongress.
Er hat da auch, wie gesagt, vor drei Jahren
einen Talk gehalten. Mit Kunst die Gesellschaft
hacken, hieß der.
Die damaligen Aktionen,
die zu dem Zeitpunkt existierten,
die wichtigsten. Unglaublich cool.
Die haben irgendwie auch wo Kreuze für
Mauertote abportiert.
Die da beim
Reichstag am Fluss in Berlin sind.
Und haben die nach
Labedusa gefahren.
An die europäische Außengrenze.
Und da, wo wirklich Leute an den
Mauern Europas quasi sterben,
da Aufmerksamkeit
zu schaffen. Das ist natürlich schön, dass sie dafür
Aufmerksamkeit schaffen. Es ist wirklich
ein bisschen kritisch zu sehen, dass sie
echte
Mahnmale für andere
Opfer irgendwo abrund sind. Aber die sind doch dafür da,
diese Mahnmale sind dafür da, um auf die Mauertoten
in Deutschland aufmerksam zu machen. Ist dir nicht
viel mehr getan an dem Gedenken
dieser Leute, wenn man auf die aktuellen
Mauertoten aufgenannt hat, dass die selbe Scheiße
die passiert, für die
Leute aktiv verantwortlich sind, wie damals.
Was aber an einem völlig vorbeigeht.
Dann hängen wir hier Kreuze ins Land und
finden das schön, an die zu gedenken, während gleichzeitig
nicht gerade wirklich weit
Leute auf genau dieselbe Art und Weise sterben.
Das ist unglaublich lächerlich.
Es ist bloß also, dass die ganzen Konstruktionen
vom Zentrum für politische Schönheit auch immer
so eine Komponente haben, dass
sich da auch sehr gut Leute dran reiben können und
an der Methodik
dann kritisieren.
Das wird auch diese eine Aktion,
die vorletzte, glaube ich,
die auch Teil des Titels vom aktuellen Vortrag ist,
von diesem Flüchtling, der sich in Berlin hat fressen lassen wollen,
öffentlich als Protestaktion.
Die hat auch ein bisschen angerieben, könnte man sagen.
Aber da will ich es nicht vorwegnehmen.
Das wird in dem Talk sicherlich thematisiert werden.
Hast du noch andere interessante Sachen auf dem Hafenab?
Es gibt nur ein paar coole andere Sachen.
Also im Hafenab findet sich so einiges.
Spannend wird sicherlich auch der Talk über
die ganze PC-Wahl-Sache.
Bin ich froh ein bisschen drauf. Also die Software möchte ich mal sehen.
Die war in Pascal. Delphi.
Das ist halt bald.
Es gibt dieses Jahr wieder ein Hacker-Jeopardy.
Ja.
Ich freue mich dir richtig. Der organisiert das eigentlich. Das haben doch ein paar Jahre lang
die Dresden organisiert, oder? Echt?
Das war quasi
die gleiche Akte. Das war der Grund, warum
das Hacker-Jeopardy
bei den Datenspuren
nicht aufgezeichnet wurde, weil sie die gleichen
Fragen dann nochmal im Prozess
Da musst du es doch als Teilnehmer
versprechen, dass du dann
beim Kongress nicht immer
teilen musst.
WinKorekt muss auch wiedergeben, auch sehr cool.
Der PC-Wall-Hack ist ja eines der Themen,
auf jeden Fall.
TuWatt ist,
das Motto wird SagWatt, oder?
Das Motto ist TuWatt.
Und SagWatt ist
die Podcast-Tisch.
TuWatt ist ja, soweit ich es richtig verstanden
habe, die Überschrift gewesen
von, womit alles
angefangen hat im CCC,
womit diese Zeitung an unsere geschaltet wurde,
damals war es sogar von Wauholland,
bin ich gar nicht sicher, wahrscheinlich,
um Leute erstmal zusammenzufinden,
tuwatt.txt, beziehungsweise wurde gedruckt
als tuwatt,txt, bei Zeitung.
Und
um Leute zu finden, die
ähnliche Interessen haben
und sich mal zusammenfinden können.
Also der ursprüngliche Aufruf für den Chaos Commitment Club, oder wie?
Der ursprüngliche Aufruf, um ihn mal zusammenzufinden,
um zu organisieren, genau.
Im Entertainment-Track wird es wieder
methodisch inkorrekt geben.
Und noch so ein paar andere Sachen, die ich jetzt nicht ganz...
Was ich auch interessant finde, ist,
dass Marc-Uwe Kling
einen Talk hält. Ja, stimmt, das habe ich gehört.
Über die Idee von Quality Land,
sein Buch.
Das ist vielleicht so ein bisschen
so eine Marketing-Aktion sein.
Wer weiß, vielleicht ein bisschen.
Können wir auch ganz cool vorstellen.
natürlich gibt es richtig viel wieder. Was ich auch richtig
cool finde, ist, dass der Science Track immer weiter ausgebaut wird.
Das ist ja ein paar coole Talks für.
Aber diesmal weiß ich,
ein paar Sachen, die ich auch spannend finde.
Ich würde ja
gerne mal
einen Vortrag von dem Typen
hören, der diese ganzen
AfD und Pegida Facebook-Gruppen
infiltriert hatte.
Das wäre ein bisschen aufwitzig.
Der hat, glaube ich, auch Morddrohungen gehört.
Also nochmal so eine Referenz, das war
glaube ich, Logbuch Netzpolitik
die Folgesuchung war raus und schreiben es mit in die
Shownotes.
Es gab irgendeinen, der durch
Social Engineering irgendwie Mitglied
und irgendwann Admin von relativ vielen
so lokalen AfD-Facebook-Gruppen
wurde und die dann glaube ich
einfach irgendwann alle zugemacht hat oder
Leute gekickt hat. Er hat dann
ziemlich krassen Scheiß gemacht, um die Leute
irgendwie vorzuführen.
Das habe ich bloß gesehen, du hast einen
unter dem Entertainment-Track
gibt es einen, der heißt Inside AfD.
Stimmt.
und ich glaube wir tun dem Zuhörer
jetzt oder der Zuhörerin keinen Gefallen
wenn wir jetzt hier einfach Sachen vorlesen
also geht mal auf
halfnarb
h-a-l-f
n-a-g-o-n-a-g-o-n-a-g-o-n-a-g-o-n
für die größte Menge von Leuten keine Überschneidung von Talks gibt,
die sie sehen möchten.
Genau.
Ich glaube, die Sachen, die wir in unser HackMD-Pad geschrieben haben,
die sind auch alle nicht mehr wirklich angemessen.
Achso, haben wir schon mal über HackMD geredet?
Nee, das war tatsächlich damals Thema,
als wir angefangen haben, da drinnen mal zu kopieren.
Ja, genau.
Also wir haben ja am Anfang mal ein bisschen in einer Folge
über unterschiedliche Collab-Tools geredet.
Und eins, was uns daraufhin
und das alle kacke sind,
eins, was uns daraufhin von
Mick empfohlen würde, war HackMD.
War das von Schmittlauch oder von Mick?
Ich glaube von Mick.
Oder von Schmittlauch. Groß an beide übrigens.
Das könnte jeder von beiden gewesen sein.
Und das ist einfach so ein
Markdown-Editor mit Vorschau
und du loggst dich
mit deinem, wenn du das nicht selber hostest,
loggst du dich mit O-Raus ein.
Du kannst es selber hosten.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich nice.
Das hat einen Vim- und E-Mex-Modus
ist ein super schicker Markdown-Editor,
quasi ein hosted Visivik Markdown-Editor.
Du kannst natürlich auch die Preview wegschalten,
wenn sie sich stört. Genau. Und das Schöne ist, du kannst
in den Buchmodus wechseln, dann wird quasi direkt
ein Git-Buch erzeugt.
Oder du kannst in den Präsentationsmodus wechseln,
dann wird daraus direkt eine Präsentation erzeugt.
Verstaunlich gut durchdachtes Tool. Finde ich super
angenehm für das Tool. Es wird von ein paar Chinesen
entwickelt und es läuft unter irgendeiner
Buy-as-a-Coffee-Lizenz.
Schön. Ist eine Node-Anwendung.
Genau.
Und ich schaue ja gerade in unserer Pad-Reihe, ich glaube,
Die Themen sind alle so ein bisschen abgelaufen.
Gezielte nächste
Aufnahmedatum.
Sag's nicht, sag's nicht.
3. Oktober.
Ja.
Wir müssen, glaube ich, mal ein bisschen
das Tempo wieder anziehen.
Wir haben ein paar Sachen noch damals
überlegt gehabt. Eine Sache, die ich auch mal
ansprechen wollte, aber wir haben noch nicht geschafft
haben. Dann sprichst du jetzt lieber
nicht ein, oder? Ja doch, es ist ja jetzt nicht abgelaufen.
Das ist das Thema der Messenger
noch mal kurz angeschnitten. Nämlich haben wir zu dem
Zeitpunkt, als das hier gerade aktuell war, das Pad,
beide nochmal mit Wire rumgespielt.
Oh ja, genau. Wir haben die Koordination
für die
Veröffentlichung der letzten Folge komplett über
Wire gemacht.
Ich habe Wire, glaube ich, 2014 mal ausprobiert
gehabt und war damals ein bisschen underwhelmed.
Aber vor kurzem nochmal reingeschaut.
Es ist erstaunlich
gut geworden. Es ist ein verdammt guter
Cross-Platform-Messenger. Die mobilen Apps sind alle
nativ. Man hat eine saubere End-to-End-Verschlüsselung.
Die nutzt das Axolotl-Protokoll.
wo es halt selbst in Rust neu implementiert.
Da gibt es ein witziges Detail,
sodass die Signal-Leute,
beziehungsweise im Oxymal-Enspike
da wohl ein bisschen sehr komisch drauf sind,
was das Verwenden von Axolotl
beziehungsweise von dem Verschlüsselungs-Algorithmus angeht.
Ach so.
Also im Sinne von, ja, ihr dürft das verwenden,
aber hier sind nur Binarys
und wir wollen bitte eine Million Dollar dafür haben.
Was?
Das ist super weird.
Ich dachte, das ist doch Open Source, ne?
Ja, aber...
Beziehungsweise...
Das heißt halt nicht,
dass du es einfach verwenden darfst.
Je nach Rezenstechnik
könnt ihr halt trotzdem machen,
was sie wollen.
Okay.
Die waren richtig komisch drauf,
gerade was ihre Intellectual Property an der Verschlüsselung angeht.
Das hat einfach nicht in mein persönliches Bild von Moxy gemacht.
Ich dachte, Moxy hatte irgendwann gesagt,
naja, wir können Signal gerne retieren,
sobald andere Messenger irgendwie anständige Krypto verwenden.
Der war doch kurz davor, Signal nicht mehr weiterzuentwickeln,
als die Axolotl in WhatsApp eingebaut hatten.
Ja, und dann haben sie ja noch WhatsApp so komisch verteidigt,
als es da so ein bisschen komische Sachen gab.
Aber das haben wir dahingestellt.
Wire macht das richtig schön. Das Backend von Wire
ist in Haskell implementiert, was ich super
spannend finde.
Alles Open Source mittlerweile? Alles Open Source
und was ist das geilste Feature überhaupt? Das ist noch
kein Feature, das geht aktuell noch nicht, aber sie
planen das, dass du Federation Support
hast. Du kannst, so dass dir einfach in Zukunft
das Ding selber hausten könnt ins Backend und dann hast
du die Möglichkeit, dass da verschiedene
Server miteinander reden und jeder seine eigene
quasi Username, Ad-Servername oder so
wie auch immer, wie man es ja von E-Mail oder
Mastodon oder Alten oder Jabber
oder Federated Services halt eben kennt.
Finde ich unglaublich cool.
Also die machen gefühlt alles richtig, die Wire-Leute.
Also es war,
man kann es ohne weiteres als
Replacement für WhatsApp und alle
anderen Messenger auf dem Handy einfach nur
nehmen, man muss es nicht auf dem Desktop verwenden, obwohl die
Desktop-App ziemlich gut ist. Die Desktop-App
ist glaube ich nicht mal eine Elektron-App.
Doch, doch. Die Desktop-App ist eine Elektron-App,
fühlt sich aber nicht so an.
Sie hat ja mittlerweile auch eine Desktop-App.
Ja, auch eine Elektron-App.
Die tut sich ja wieder mehr danach an.
Da kannst du witzigerweise zwischen dem
iOS und dem Android 4 hin und her
schalten.
Aber was wirklich so
das eine Killer Feature von Wire für mich ist,
dass es dein Account nicht an deine Telefonnummer
bindet. Kurze
Warning, wenn ihr aufgrund dieser Tatsache,
dass wir gerade darüber reden, euch Wire installieren
wollt, tatsächlich, wenn ihr
die mobile App, also wenn ihr euch
versucht, einen neuen Account über die mobile App anzulegen,
da seid ihr an die Telefonnummer gebunden, das ist bekannt,
das wollen die ändern. Ihr könnt euch den Account aber genauso
gut am Desktop anlegen oder über app.wire.com
im Browser zum Beispiel
und da kann man sich dann mit einer
E-Mail-Adresse registrieren. Also es fühlt sich
nur so komisch an, dass man mit der Mobil-App
über die Telefonnummer den Zwang hat.
Ich weiß nicht, warum sie das so machen aktuell. Ich habe schon
nachgefragt, aber keine sinnvolle Antwort bekommen.
Nur, dass sie es halt irgendwann ändern wollen.
Aber man ist über die anderen Plattformen eben nicht
daran gebunden und kann sich dann natürlich mit diesem
dort an der bereitgestellten Account natürlich auch
wieder anmelden und das dann halt dann nutzen.
Das ist jetzt aber ziemlich sportlich schnell runtergespült.
Wenn jemand diese Folge wieder in anderthalbfacher Geschwindigkeit hört,
dann muss er kurz mal das Tempo ein bisschen unterhalten.
Okay.
E-Wire ist cool.
Ziemlich cool.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich habe gerade mal ein bisschen...
Ja, ich habe gerade mal Inventur gemacht.
Ich habe jetzt, glaube ich, fünf elektronenbasierte Messenger-Apps bei mir.
Schrecklich, oder?
Aber das Thema haben wir, glaube ich, auch bereits.
Zumindest gibt es jetzt einen mehr.
Und das ist momentan unser neuer Lieblings-Messenger.
Ach übrigens,
Heinz Steiger!
Was, wo kommst du her?
Prost!
Also es ist wirklich einfach aufgetaucht hier spontan.
Hallo Jungs, witzig.
Jetzt haben wir wirklich dieses
Freakshow-Film, wo plötzlich Leute
von außerhalb reinkommen und mit reinreden.
Bin ich auch nur im Studio.
Ja, das ist unsere erste
Folge seit...
Oh Gott.
Ich glaube, ich schaue zwei, dass dein Bruder hat.
Wir kommen jetzt langsam zu unseren Picks.
Mein Laptop
spät sich die ganze Zeit und ich kann nicht
weiterreden, während ich mein Passwort eingebe.
Ich habe nur ein Pick dieses Mal.
Dafür habe ich gleich fünf.
Dann fang du an.
Vielleicht hat der Steiger
noch einen.
Gut, dann fange ich halt mal an.
Und zwar eigentlich
das,
vielleicht kann man auch dabei bleiben,
der witzigste Pick, wo ich
vorhin über WebAssembly bereits
geredet habe, ist das GitHub-Projekt
MetalOS.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du davon gehört hast.
Ich habe ja bei uns in der Umgebung auch, gerade hier in Dresden,
relativ viele Betriebssystem-affine
Menschen. Dresden ist ja auch so
ein bisschen die Micro-Kernel-
Hauptstadt Deutschlands.
Die Leute aus Karlsruhe beschränken sie jetzt vielleicht nicht.
MetalOS
ist ein Betriebssystem-Kernel,
ein Unikernel in Rust geschrieben.
Natürlich.
Also es ist tatsächlich
ein Unit-Körnel,
der nur
WebAssembly-Anwendungen ausführen kann
und die direkt im
Ring 0 im Kernel ausführt
und dadurch, dass das allerdings
WebAssembly so ein
wohl definiertes
WebAssembly ist quasi
ein vor allem ausführbarer
Code.
Kannst du die relativ gut einschränken, die können
nicht weit raus. Das ist ein bisschen, als ob du
JavaScript direkt im Kernel ausführen würdest.
Aber warum will man das?
Ich überlege gerade,
wenn du dann Metal brauchst,
also ein Ringwilz, brauchst du ja vor allem wieder.
Ja genau, was du da drin
ausführst.
So wie das Minix, was letztens
jemand, der durch die
Online-Medien, dass irgendwie
jeder Intel-CPU
auf Ring-1 und Minus-2 irgendwie so
ein extra OS-Milics
laufen hat, was quasi
Zucker auf alles hat und
du hast keine Ahnung, dass es überhaupt da ist.
Ja, aber für MetalOS, das klingt natürlich
interessant irgendwie. Vor allem, wenn du
recht viel reinkriegst. Und WebAssembly ist ja eher so
Byte-Code. WebAssembly
ist Assembly, was von einem
JavaScript-Jit-Compiler ausgeführt wird.
Das hört sich interessant,
an, wo bald alle Note
schreiben. Also das Projekt hat
momentan 47 Commits.
Das klingt interessant.
Das ist ein ziemlich
witziges Thema.
So, du. Ich habe
ein Spiel entdeckt vor ein paar Tagen über
Hacker News namens Endless Sky.
Das liegt auf GitHub,
komplett in Zipro-Tus geschrieben. Hat ungefähr
100 Mal so viele Commits wie dein
Projekt gerade, wie 4300.
Was aber nichts
ausgesagt hat in irgendeiner Weise.
wenn ihr Spiele kennt wie Elite
Dangerous oder Escape Velocity
oder
Nova hieß das glaube ich so Top Down
Space
Top Down Space klingt immer ein bisschen komisch
wo ist eigentlich oben
du spielst halt auf so einer Zeite Ebene
von oben schauend fliegst du mit Schraubenschrift durchs All
und tradest und greifst Piraten an
unglaublich cool Open Source Projekt
kannst du dir die
Binary direkt für Mac OS und
Windows unterladen, für die du musst du selber bauen
aber es spielt sich echt cool
macht tierisch Spaß
Endless Sky
So ein ähnliches Spiel, was ich früher mal gespielt habe
ist jetzt vor kurzem auf GitHub gelandet
ich weiß nicht, ob ich es nochmal wieder fände
das hieß Schiffbruch
das war von irgendeinem Deutschen entwickelt worden
das war so ein bisschen
das war so ein bisschen wie Minecraft
du bist auf einer Insel gelandet
die wurde generiert
das war so ein
45 Grad Draufsicht
Strategiespiel
musstest dir halt relativ schnell aus Holz
Werkzeuge bauen und dir dann eine Hütte bauen,
weil du nachts von Wölfen gefressen wurdest.
Und irgendwie hast du dann
Touren um die Insel gemacht und dann lag manchmal
irgendwo am Strand, konntest du immer so ein bisschen
rausschwimmen, waren manchmal irgendwelche Schiffwracks,
wo du Zeugs rausziehen konntest.
Genau, Schiffbruch. Supergeiles
Spiel. Ich hab's leider nicht
kompiliert gekriegt, aber wenn man's
immer wieder zum Laufen kriegen würde, würde ich
das sogar mal wieder eine Runde spielen.
Ich muss gerne mal ein paar Bilder davon sehen.
Wippo haben wir auch mal mit in die Shownos rein.
Genau.
Von Dirk Plate.
Genau, das ist...
Der hatte witzige Partikeleffekte,
wenn du die Maus im Menü bewegt hattest.
So pixelische Gegner.
Ich habe mir damals gedacht, boah,
so viel Performance
auf meinem Windows ME,
auf dem ich das ausgeführt habe.
Genau.
Steiger, kannst du ein cooles
Gitarre-Projekt, was du empfehlen könntest?
Ich habe gerade nochmal meine Stars durchgeschaut,
aber ich sehe es gerade nicht. Ich habe auch keine Technik mit.
Ich bin ja wirklich spontan dumm gekommen.
Der arme Typ wusste gar nicht, dass wir gerade podcasten.
Ja.
Er hat ein Bier in der Hand, er ist prima vorbereitet.
Genau.
Nein, aber ich könnte vielleicht noch etwas erzählen.
Es war ja auch eine Cloud-Native-Meetup in Dresden vor zwei Wochen.
Ah.
Da würde ich vielleicht später noch kurz was dazu erzählen wollen.
Vielleicht nehmen wir einfach im Anschluss Folge 12 auf.
Nein.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr uns wieder so aufmerksam zugehört habt.
Ach, ist der Schluss?
Was?
ich dachte, wir machen jetzt Schluss.
Ja, das war einfach weiter.
Weil ich dann trotzdem so spontan komme.
Du hast doch gesagt,
fünf Picks und dann
du sagst, was ich sagst und dann
vielleicht so zugehört hat.
Gut, okay.
Gut, also einen Pick hätte ich noch.
Und zwar
kennst du WTF-8?
Nein. WTF-8 ist
ein etwas
schwammig, aber
wohl definiertes
Superset von UTF-8,
was von Simon
Sapin entwickelt wird, einem Mozilla-Mitarbeiter.
Ich fand's
hauptsächlich witzig, weil es
WTF-8 heißt und Superset von
UTF-8 ist.
Es ist quasi um so Reibungsverluste
zwischen Textkodierung,
zwischen JavaScript und Windows
und UTF-8 zu kaschieren.
Okay.
Also, naja,
JavaScript-Strings
sind UTF-16-Strings
eigentlich. Was ein Problem ist,
wenn du zum Beispiel Code in
Rust schreibst und den in WebAssembly
mit JavaScript verknüpfen musst, hast du halt immer,
du kannst nicht einfach
Rust-Code schreiben, einfach so, du
musst Interfaces anbieten, die C-kompatibel sind.
Dementsprechend machst du die ganze Zeit
FFI quasi und dementsprechend
musst du, wenn du Strings und
JavaScript in Genen nimmst, die von UTF-16 nach
UTF-8 konvertieren.
Verstehe. Und da helfen
mir solche Tools hier auch so ein bisschen mit.
Das fand ich ziemlich cool, könnt ihr euch mal angucken.
Schön ist, dass das Logo so ein defekt
kodiertes
Coding-Symbol ist.
Also kommt mit
in die Show Notes.
WTF-8.
Ja, ich glaube,
das reicht.
Also vielen Dank, dass ihr uns...
Wir können es jetzt an dieser Stelle
langsam ausklingen lassen.
Das war Folge
11, akronomisierbar.
0-1, genau.
Oder 2.
Nein, drei. Oh mein Gott, Folge
drei? Folge drei bin er krediert.
Vielen Dank, dass
ihr uns zugehört habt. Ihr findet uns
wie gewohnt auf Twitter
am besten auf
atakronomisierbar und unseren
Feed könnt ihr abonnieren auf
feed.akronomisier.bar
Und die nächste
Folge in eurem Podcatcher
beginnt in drei,
zwei,
eins,
so.
Druck, Druck, Druck, Druck.
Sorry, wir müssen jetzt ganz leise sein.
Übrigens, weil es gerade noch weiter läuft.
Oh mein Gott, die Aufnahme ist da aktiv.
Nicht, dass die Leute denken, wir machen jetzt den Track
oder so.
Psst.
Vielleicht haben die ja gar nichts weiteres im Podcast.
Im Podcast.
Und dann denken die, ist einfach wirklich Schluss.
Vielleicht.
Ich glaube, wir schneiden einfach ein bisschen Luft mit rein, oder?
Ja, ja.
Ja, warten lassen.
Okay, wollen wir weitermachen?
Ja, da sind wir wieder.
Das ist der erste Podcast
mit einem Hidden Track.
Wir hören uns nicht gerade entschlossen,
weil Steiger gerade hier ist und von einem interessanten
Thema berichten kann. Machen wir jetzt gleich
quasi ein Hidden Chapter und reden jetzt einfach weiter.
Ja, ich bin
ja nur spontan rumgekommen und
vor
zwei Wochen oder so war in Dresden
ein ganz interessantes Mieter.
Da ging es um Cloud Native und Kubernetes
und das ist ja sehr interessant für mich.
War bei einem bekannten
Unternehmen, die haben da richtig viel springen lassen,
so mit Schnittchen und Bier und ja,
ist auch ganz schön viel weggegangen. Bei einem bekannten
Unternehmen? Ja, unten
neben Zwinger direkt, neben
Stadtspiel, Schauspielhaus.
Ach du meinst Lock Me In?
Ja, genau. Und die haben das richtig
cool veranstaltet.
Gab zwei Talks und... Ich wollte eigentlich
hin, du hast mir nicht davon erzählt.
Hätte eigentlich nach der Arbeit einfach
da bleiben müssen. Ich hab's irgendwie nicht mitbekommen.
Dann kommen wir das nächste Mal mit. Ich glaub, es ist bei
LaVue. Aber ich hab jetzt noch nicht reingeschaut.
Das nächste ist dann bei LaVue.
Das war wirklich bei euch. Ja, na klar.
Das andere war bei mir.
Ich dachte grad, das war bei SAP.
Das war der Witz.
Nee, SAP
aber das nächste ist bei LaVue.
Es waren ganz viele von LaVue da.
Von den Ops-Leuten.
Und die haben dann gemeint, hey, das können wir bei uns
eigentlich auch mal hosten demnächst.
Kann ich doch nicht nach Arbeit da bleiben.
Da muss ich zu Labou rüberlatschen.
Wir waren bei euch im Felsenkaller unten.
Und es war sehr angenehm.
Viele Leute getroffen.
Willi zum Beispiel.
Wir hatten zwei coole Themen.
Das eine war
ein Typ von Zalando.
Ein Portugiese.
Der arbeitet in Berlin.
Die haben eigentlich coole Themen.
Die blocken manchmal auch interessante Sachen.
Zalando hat einen coolen Teil.
Schuhe interessieren mich jetzt nicht ganz so sehr.
Nee, aber die haben auch andere Klamotten.
Ach ja, okay. Ja, du merkst schon.
Und der hat
im Prinzip erstmal so ein Roundup gegeben,
was die so fahren und wie das bei denen aussieht.
Und das ist ganz schön viel Infrastruktur.
Die haben viele coole Sachen gebaut
für halt so diesen ganzen
Cloud-Kram, den man halt so kennt.
Zweiten Talk gab es
dann von den LogMeIn-Leuten. Da hat jemand
seine Leidensgeschichte in den letzten
fünf Jahren Kubernetes mal beschrieben
und war dann schon ein bisschen
betroffen, wo ich mir das alles
angehört habe, wie sehr er dort gelitten hat.
Ich weiß gar nicht, habt ihr so ein Spezialbüro
Stefan und Stefan oder so? Ne.
Stefan und Stefan?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich kenne gerade keinen Stefan.
Ist egal. Auf jeden Fall war es sehr interessant,
sehr nett. Tut mir leid Stefan, vielleicht habe ich dich jetzt einfach
bloß gerade vergessen.
Nee, vielleicht habe ich es auch einfach nur verwechselt.
Die Hürde fürs Gedächtnis
war ja danach, konnte ich irgendwie noch
zehn Leute motivieren, bis wir um die Ecke in die Kneipe
dort irgendwie hintergeben.
Pulverturm, Schieß...
Keine Ahnung. Es gab auf jeden Fall
nochmal eine ganze Runde hier.
Was den ganzen
Abend auf jeden Fall sehr gut abgerundet hat.
Und ich freue mich
auf jeden Fall, weil 40 Leute dort waren.
Krass. Das ist viel.
Das ist mega viel. Und vor allem
hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass
das so coole Leute sind und das
so eine offene Atmosphäre
war, wo man wirklich mal mitbekommen hat,
wie viel die ganzen Leute eigentlich mit
alle mit demselben Wasser kochen
und
an welchen Stellen halt jeder irgendwie
die Probleme gerade mit der Technik hat.
Das erdet so ein bisschen und man kriegt aber auch mit,
wie man irgendwelche komischen Probleme löst.
Oder zum Beispiel bei Zalando war halt der Vortrag
ganz interessant, weil die im Prinzip
ihr komplettes Basement, ihre komplette
Plattform selber bauen.
Also das ist unglaublich.
Die sind halt irgendwie bei Amazon,
haben mehrere
Dutzend Cluster bei Amazon laufen.
sehr harte Anforderungen
und das ist schon richtig gut durchgeplant.
Nicht schlecht. Ja, dann hat er das mal erklärt
und wir machen das so und so und so.
Also eine sauber Architektur.
Keine Ahnung, ob ich bei Zalando was einkaufen würde,
aber arbeiten klingt
ganz mal interessant.
Die haben bei Zalando auch manchmal so
Hackwigs oder so arbeitiges Zeugs basteln.
Ja, und 15 Tools
geforkt und mit Z vorne benannt.
War das eigentlich auch unter einer Liste von
Startups mit dem Ohr am Ende.
Zalando, ja. Ich habe mich immer gefragt,
warum diese ganzen Firmen alle so Zalando,
Lovo,
Trivago,
Opodo.
Ein bisschen Schema.
Diese ganzen deutschen Firmen heißen gefühlt
alle gleich. Aber kann man sich diese Meetup-Talks,
die du da gehört hast, irgendwo nachträglich
angucken? Wurden die irgendwie aufgezeichnet?
Ja, es gibt auf jeden Fall in der Meetup-Gruppe
Kubernetes und Cloud-Native
Computing Dresden.
ein paar Leute, die haben das irgendwie
geshared und ich hatte auch vorgeschlagen,
lasst uns das machen, wie bei Akronomisierbar
auf GitHub und das Zeug dort hochladen.
In Repos und auch mit...
Hast du dort in der Gruppe von uns geredet?
Vielleicht.
Was machen wir Sinnvolles?
Ich habe vergessen, das wird ein GitHub-Über.
Also ihr habt zumindest einen coolen Workflow,
wo Sachen aufgreift und
euch merkt.
Ich glaube, wir schauen da nie rein.
Open Source Development Patterns for Podcasting.
Das ist auf jeden Fall sehr gut.
Es ist erstaunlich viel nach GitHub gewandert.
Dafür, dass es ein kommerzielles Unternehmen ist,
das ist ein cooles, entspanntes,
recht transparentes
kommerzielles Unternehmen, aber es ist ein kommerzielles Unternehmen.
Ich habe immer Angst, dass die weggehen irgendwann.
Und die gesamte Sprach-
Design-Infrastruktur für Rustlic
da, das TC39 ist mit ihren
Proposals dorthin gezogen.
Das ist ja witzig, wenn die Cocoa-Ports-Leute,
dieser iOS-Package-Manager,
die haben ja öfter mal zusammenreinend
mit GitHub gehabt, weil die wohl
im Specs-Repo alleine bei GitHub verantwortlich sind.
Oder war es CocoaPods oder Homebrew?
Einer von beiden, die haben irgendwie vier dediziertes
Maschinen bei GitHub, die nur dieses
Repo hosten.
Und da kommt GitHub immer wieder vorbei.
So eben, ich weiß ja, performance-mäßig, wir haben
immer ein paar Bottle-Nex bei euch identifiziert, wie ihr das
generell ein bisschen umbauen könnt, das Tool, damit das
ein bisschen weniger Last bei uns erzeugt. Wir sind generell
dedicated to our mission, von wegen, hier
for free host it ever, für immer, aber
ein bisschen optimieren können wir da schon.
Ja, also ja, viele Leute
benutzen das halt einfach irgendwie und machen sich dann
keine Gedanken, was da eigentlich
im Hintergrund passiert. Wir hatten uns auch mal für den
Invisor darüber unterhalten, ob man irgendwie
Git anfragen kann auf dem Server Remote, ob sich
was geändert hat, damit man nicht jedes Mal einen Pull machen muss.
Oder einen Fetch.
Ich wollte mal nachgucken, ob man so eine Art
Header-Only-Fetch
machen könnte.
Ja, das wäre bei Git auf jeden Fall
mal sehr interessant, weil dann kann man auch
das System wieder für andere Dinge missbrauchen.
So Update-Notifications und so ein Zeug.
Das wäre schon recht praktisch.
Ich habe heute mal ein bisschen rumgebastelt,
aber ich habe vorhin schon erzählt, leider nicht im Podcast,
aber wer es hiermit erzählt, ein bisschen
eine eigene Kryptowährung
slash Blockchain Basic Implementation
mal zu basteln, weil es super Spaß gemacht hat.
Und ich habe kurz ein bisschen mit der Idee gespielt,
als Backing-Storage doch einfach ein Public-Git-Webote
wo ich die Blöcke reinschmeiße.
Wenn du grob darüber nachdenkst,
ist ja Git
so eine Art Blockchain-Filesystem.
Git ist so eine Art NoSQL-Datenbank, genau.
Also ich habe ja, du hast gerade
den Invoice angesprochen, ich habe ja für unser
Studentencafé so ein kleines Tool gebaut, wo man
einfach Projekte erstellen und verwalten kann.
Und weil ich keine Web-Anwendung bauen
wollte, habe ich einfach Dateien gespeichert
und plötzlich musste man
mit anderen Leuten zusammenarbeiten,
also mit dem Server synchronisieren, deswegen habe ich einfach Git eingebaut.
Wenn du darüber nachdenkst,
ist es eine
NoSQL-Blockchain-basierte
Datenbank. Prinzipiell genau das, ja.
Ich meine, ich schreibe da Dateien in Ordner
und synchronisieren.
Eine Beide-System-basierte NoSQL-Blockchain-Datenbank.
schnell und für sehr viel
Performance bekannt.
Da hat ja auch jetzt Microsoft
noch was weiter angeht.
Das ist ein Virtual File System.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die bei Microsoft arbeiten,
ob die da auch so ein Monorepo haben,
wie bei Google oder so.
Ich glaube kein Monorepo, aber für die Windows
haben sie ja mittlerweile auch, glaube ich,
über Git komplett versioniert.
Ja, eben. Also Microsoft setzt halt auch richtig
stark Git ein und haben halt festgestellt,
okay, wir haben so viel Code bei uns,
Git kriegt das einfach nicht hin.
Allein die Diffs machen
und allein festzustellen, welche Dereien sich geändert haben
von einem Comet,
killt einfach mal Git auf dem Windows-Qualcode.
Das hatten die Facebook-Leute ja auch gehabt
vor ein paar Jahren, weil die haben ja auch
das Monorepo-Problem, aber die haben ja generell
auch mit dem einen Projekt mit Facebook schon nicht.
Und deswegen haben die irgendwie eine Art Meta-Layer
dazwischen gelegt im Datei-System, um sich
schon mal zu merken, was sich geändert hat,
damit das Git-Comet dann nicht mehr
alle Dateien angucken muss, sondern damit dann
im Prinzip das Datei-System sagt, ach übrigens sind folgende
Sachen aufgelaufen.
Die Leute haben sich beschwert, dass es das noch nicht für Linux gibt.
Ja, die haben das mit Microsoft-Ball gemacht.
Baut das ja kompatibel tatsächlich.
Die müssen dafür quasi Patches an den Linux-Körnel
einstellen.
Warum müssen wir das unbedingt machen?
Für Windows haben sie es auch gemacht. Sie haben tatsächlich den Windows-Körnel
auch angepasst, damit
Git Virtual File System auch funktioniert.
Es gibt ja bei Windows
direkt sehr problemlos
so User-Space-Datei-System-Treiber.
Also genau wie Fuse unter Linux gibt es das
halt auch für Windows und da gibt es dann noch
Extended-Treiber und ich glaube XFS und
Aber wer weiß, ob wir in ein paar Jahren
überhaupt alle noch Git verwenden.
Es gibt ja sowas wie Mercurial.
Da wäre so ein Monorepo schon fast ein bisschen besser machbar.
Das ist ja etwas Facebook gemacht.
Weil die partielle Checkouts unterstützen.
Das heißt, es gibt ja so geile neue Build-Systeme
wie Bazel oder sowas.
Wenn du das mit deinem Code-Verwaltungstool
anständig verknüpfen kannst,
kannst du dem sagen,
ich muss überhaupt nicht alles auschecken.
Sondern ich muss, ich sage einfach,
ich ziehe mir das Repo flach.
Also ich habe nur so ein Cello-Clone quasi
und dann sage ich Build
und dann klont er nur die Dateien, die ich für
dieses spezielle Build-Target, was ich jetzt bauen will,
brauche. Das wäre eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Das wäre auf jeden Fall mal ein Schritt nach vorne.
Wie gesagt, vielleicht benutzen wir in ein paar Jahren
alle Mercurial,
weil Mercurial jetzt bekannt gegeben hat,
dass sie mittelfristig
ihr Tool,
was ja bislang vornehmlich in Python geschrieben ist,
Git ist in C geschrieben, Mercurial ist in Python geschrieben.
Jetzt war man einfach nur in Per geschrieben.
Ja, Teile von Git sind auch in Perl
und Bash geschrieben
und Python, aber egal. Die wollen zumindest
von ihrer
Python-Implementierung mittelfristig wegmigrieren
und alles in Raston reinschreiben.
Nicht alles.
Großteil. Sie haben irgendwie noch Teile, ich hab mich
leider mit MacRae nicht so ausgiebig beschäftigt,
aber du kannst ja irgendwie auch Teile in
Python dazu skripten
und die wollen quasi ihren eigenen Python-Interpreter
mitliefern. Das heißt, du hast dann einen,
du startest dann kein
HG-Binary mehr, was ein Python-Script ist
und andere Python-Scripts dann
included, sondern du startest das Ding, was dann
in Rust-Binary ist und
in Python-Interpreter beinhaltet. Das fand ich übrigens
sehr spannend in der Hacker-News-Diskussion dazu,
weil es explizit erstmal
vorerst nicht darum ging,
dass quasi die unterste Ebene
auszutauschen, sondern dass es immer noch ein Python-Tool bleibt,
was irgendwo ein paar in Rust
implementierte Ecken hat, aber
der größte Performance-Engpass, den sie angesprochen
haben, war die Startup-Time von dem Ding an sich,
einfach lahm anfühlt. Auch wenn das Ding
ziemlich schnell läuft.
Das ist für Kommando-Zahlen-Tools ist das der
Tod. Also dieses kleine Tool, was wir
gerade eben erwähnt hatten, diesen Invoice,
den hatte ich ursprünglich in Ruby geschrieben.
Und ob der was gemacht hat oder nicht,
wenn du das Ding gestartet hast, hat der
fast eine Sekunde gebraucht, um überhaupt irgendwas
zu machen. Egal, ob es viel war oder nicht.
Und das kriegst du einfach nicht runter bei so einem
Tool. Da gibt es so einen Closure-Repple,
der hat das ganz witzig gelöst.
Der hat da eine ganz dünne, ich meine
so, ich hoffe gleich, ich habe keinen Scheiß, aber ich meine,
es war eine ganz dünne Bash-Ebene drum gelegt,
um das Repple an sich,
der dir einfach schon mal quasi die, in Anführungsstrichen,
UI anzeigt und Input
entgegennimmt, aber im Hintergrund, dass Repple
startet und bis du das erste Mal Enter gedrückt hast,
hat er das Repple gestartet gehabt und es fühlte
sich einfach viel flotter an, auch wenn der
erst natürlich nicht für Input wirklich zur Verfügung stand
beim Anfang an, aber es war halt
schon mal was da, du konntest tippen und das wurde dann
an das Repple, sobald es gestartet hat, weitergereicht.
Also quasi so wie System, die
TCP-Sockets offen hält für dich und den Dienst erst
startet, wenn du das erste Byte...
Achso, ja, ich habe eine Idee, genau.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wie der Login-Screen von Mac,
der so aussieht...
Von MacOS, der so aussieht, als wäre das Ding
schon komplett hochgefahren, dann gibst du dein Passwort ein
und dann wartest du nochmal zwei Minuten, bis es wirklich
komplett hochgefahren ist.
Da gab es diesen getritten Bug-Off.
Hast du das auch mitbekommen von dem Typen?
Wir haben doch dringend geschrieben.
Nicht die eine Root-Lücke, sondern die andere.
Von wegen, Typ gibt im Login-Dialog
dein Passwort ein, hat merkt, oh, das Login-Dialog
war nicht im Fokus,
klickt in das Passwortfeld rein,
gibt das Passwort, lockt sich an, oh, im Hintergrund war Stack
im Fokus und er hat mit dem ersten Input sein Passwort
an alle Teammitglieder geschickt.
What? Das darf halt echt nicht sein.
Ah ah.
Das, was hinter dem Passwort-Dialog im Fokus
und den Input abnimmt.
Ah ah.
Ja, ich glaube, also, um ganz kurz
an das Thema anzusteigen, aber
echt nur ganz kurz, ich glaube, Apple tut sich
im Moment überhaupt keinen Gefallen.
Nee, aber ich hoffe,
Ich bin schwer enttäuscht über die Softwarequalität.
Das ist so komplex geworden.
Es sind so viele Sachen, die einfach gerade überhaupt nicht gehen.
iOS, das sind...
Ich höre ganz viele Leute rumheulen,
dass irgendwelche Dinge nicht gehen.
Die I'm Root-Lücke oder...
Das ist unglaublich.
Da habe ich kurz einen Bericht darüber gelesen, wie das ging.
Wie das möglich war.
Ich kann es in Teilen wiedergeben.
Ich habe einen Return-Code nicht ordentlich interpretiert gehabt.
Ja, die haben eine Update-Funktion.
Ich dachte, das war irgendwie ein Problem,
dass sie einen internen Passwort-Store gewechselt haben
und dann beim Migrieren auf den alten zugegriffen haben
und nicht auf den neuen.
Wer vielleicht schon ein paar Jahre länger
irgendwie so Debian oder so verwendet.
Ich bin ja schon seit mehr als 10 Jahren
an der Stelle dabei.
Da gab es irgendwann mal ein Update.
Am Anfang waren die die Passwörter
in Unix-Script gespeichert.
Also Unix-Script ist halt so ein Crypt,
wo man 8 Zeichen lange Passwörter haben darf.
Und alles, was danach kommt, wird weggeschnitten.
Und es wird dann halt gehasht auf 13 Zeichen.
Das ist interessant, weil ich habe es in der Uni gemerkt.
Ja, das ging auch früher und das war ein Problem.
Auf jeden Fall gab es bei meinen ersten DBN-Versionen noch dieses Hash-Verfahren.
Und dann wurde das aktualisiert auf die EDC-Shadow-Datei mit MD5-Hashes oder sowas.
Jedenfalls gab es dann ein Update für dieses Paket, was die Passwörter verwaltet hat.
Und dann wurde man auch gefragt, möchtest du die Passwort-Datenbank hier aktualisieren oder willst du es umstellen?
Was dann darauf hinausläuft, dass die im Prinzip gesagt haben,
okay, nehmen wir die EDC-Shadow und das Skriptsystem als Vorback.
Und jedes Mal, wenn ein Nutzer seinen Kennwort geändert hat,
wurde das quasi aus der alten Datenbank gelöscht und in die neue eingetragen.
Bei Mac läuft das genauso, nur dass die dann sagen,
okay, wir gucken rein, wenn du ein altes Hash-Verfahren hast,
dann testen wir da irgendwie dagegen.
Wenn das stimmt, aktualisieren wir das halt und schreiben das neue rein.
Und dort haben die dann im Prinzip gepatzt.
Und das Ergebnis war im Prinzip, dass es halt nicht richtig abgefangen wurde.
Und das System halt einfach das leere Passwort aktualisiert hat
und ein leeres Passwort als Hash für gut
eingetragen hat. Deswegen musste man zwei Mal lock'in machen.
Beim ersten Mal wurde es geschrieben und beim zweiten Mal
schreibt es euch.
Unglaublich.
So was darf nicht sein. Aber ich finde es gar nicht
mal so falsch, dass solche Sachen
gerade so ein bisschen durch die Medien geschleift werden.
So ein bisschen Druck aufbauen
und hoffentlich ändert das wieder Dinge.
Ja, da werden Köpfe wahrscheinlich
gewollt. Also gerade wegen
sowas hoffe ich nicht, dass jemand gefeuert wird.
Okay, es gibt jetzt keinen Steve Jobs mehr.
Das ist keine Fireable Offense.
Wenn jemand mit Absicht das eingebaut hat, klar, sofort.
Der dann nicht zu suchen, aber
das ist ein Bug, aufgrund
dessen du niemals gefeuert werden solltest.
Natürlich soll es dann Postmortem geben, auch intern.
Stattdessen sollten uns lieber
ein paar Leute mehr einstellen und dann
QA machen.
QA ist so eine Sache.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man mit diesem ganz normalen
Business-Prozess-Logiken dort
das Problem ausschlagen wird.
Dass du dann mehr Leute auf das Problem kippst,
ist vielleicht so eine Sache und
du wirst halt nicht weiterkommen an der Stelle.
Ich glaube, die müssen mal ihren Fokus
wieder ein bisschen ändern.
Die achten halt eigentlich nicht drauf,
auf diese Grundlagen.
Das tut halt einfach weh.
Da ist man halt...
Ja, diese Spekulation, man weiß halt nicht leider,
wie Apple intern die Prioritäten setzt.
Das wäre schön zu wissen auf jeden Fall.
Man weiß es leider nicht.
Es gibt ganz viele Leute, die sagen,
Snow Leopard war...
Snow Leopard war mein erstes Mac OS.
War das beste Mac OS ever.
Und danach haben sie ja mit Laien angefangen,
irgendwie Vollscreen-Modus umzubauen,
Desktops umzubauen, alles mögliche komisch zu machen.
War Snow Leopard das letzte, wo man noch so
virtuelle Desktops hatte, die man
in Zweidimensionen anordnen konnte?
Ja. So wie bei KDE?
Ich glaube, das war eine Erweiterung. Das kannst du wahrscheinlich wiedergeben,
Kilian, weil ich kenne das nicht mehr.
Ich kenne
mehrdimensionale Desktop-Anordnungen
nur von Third-Party-Tools.
Ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern, dass das jemand
vielleicht war dazu, aber ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern.
Also so wie es von Ubuntu und Gnome
und KDE kennt, da hat das Mac auch mal gekannt.
Ich hatte mir, das ist ja ganz nett.
Dann haben sie halt nochmal abgeschossen.
Aber es kann sein, dass das noch irgendwo war.
Die hatten definitiv am Anfang noch
die virtuellen Desktops bei
10.6, also bei Snow Leopard war das noch mit drin.
Bei 10.7 ist deswegen diesen
Fullscreen-Mode und
der gesamten Betrachtungsweise,
wie ein Desktop funktioniert, was jetzt genau Desktop
und was Monitor ist und so, rausgeflogen.
Das war mega hässlich.
Haben sie mehrere Releases gebraucht, um das sauber hinzukriegen.
Und das geht irgendwie gefühlt immer noch nicht richtig,
weil du kannst, wenn du eine Fullscreen-Anwendung hast,
kannst du kein anderes Fenster davor haben.
wenn ich eine Anwendung Fullscreen mache und ich habe
bereits fünf Deskups,
dann wandert das ganz nach rechts.
Es sei denn nur Firefox, weil der hat irgendwie
das eigene Windows Server drin und da neue Fenster
aufmacht, dann landen die im Vollbildmodus
teilweise vor dem Fenster und das ist super weird.
Ja. Das muss ich mal ausprobieren.
Ich habe auch solche Sachen. Ich habe zum Beispiel Little Snitch
als Firewall und die fragt natürlich immer, wenn du irgendwie
ein neues Programm hast, das noch nicht kennt, gestartet hast,
darf dieses Programm auf das Internet zugreifen?
Dann kriegst du, egal ob du ein Vollbild an, im Modus bist
oder nicht, kriegst du immer so ein Pop-Up-Window.
Das ist ja kein Fenster.
Das ist schon ein Fenster, aber
dieses
ohne Menubar, was irgendwie trotzdem immer floaten.
Genau, auf jeden Fall
kommt dann ein kleines Fenster und fragt dich.
Und das Problem ist aber, manchmal verlierst du den
Fokus, vor allen Dingen, wenn du jetzt
also du hast
deinen normalen Desktop offen mit normalen Fenstern,
bist Browser und rechts
da hast du den Shell. So, jetzt bin ich auf
dem normalen Desktop und starte ein Programm.
Das braucht einen Moment zum Starten. Ich wechsle
auf die Shell und fange an zu tippen.
Jetzt kommt der Pop-up.
Gleichzeitig kommt das Fenster.
Also Fenstermanagement auf macOS ist komplett kaputt.
Dann kommt das Fenster und mein Fokus wird wieder
auf meinen normalen Desktop rübergezogen.
Mac vom Vollbild, wo ich auf der Konsole war,
zack, rüber auf die normale Anwendung blockiert,
weil Little Snitch hat den Zweigprozess blockiert.
So lange, bis ich nicht gesagt habe,
okay, ich gehe wieder rüber und es kommt einfach vor,
dass dieses Pop-Up-Fenster von meiner Fiber
in den Hintergrund rutscht.
Und ich kann nichts mehr tun.
Oh nein.
Ich kann nichts mehr tun.
Ich komme auch nicht an das Fenster ran.
Selbst wenn ich, also das normale Programm ist wie gesagt
blockiert, ich kann nicht interagieren damit.
Ich kann auch meine Konsole dann
beenden und dann wird das Ding irgendwie virtuell offen gehalten,
weil da irgendetwas drin ist, wo man nicht rankommt.
Also mir passiert es manchmal, ich stecke
mir auf Arbeit auf meinem Laptop dann zwei
externe Monitore an. Manchmal passiert
es mir, dass ich, wenn ich die abziehe,
dass meine Fenster dann halt
außerhalb meines Monitors sind.
Oh nein.
Ich habe mich einmal gehabt.
Oh, ganz schrecklich.
Der skaliert dann automatisch auch wieder runter
weil ich im Laptop-Modus bin,
dann habe ich eine geringere
virtuelle Auflösung und dann scheinen
manchmal die Ecken von den Fenstern wieder so ein bisschen
in den Bildschirm rein, dann kann ich die,
weiß ich zumindest, dass sie da sind, kann sie dann
irgendwie da reinziehen, aber Fenstermanagement,
allein die Tatsache, dass du einen Task-Switcher hast,
wo jede Anwendung einfach drin ist. Das ist aber
vielleicht einfach ein anderes Paradigma.
Aber dieses Paradigma ist funktional.
Ja, ich finde, das ist einfach,
ich habe mich da seit Jahren dran gewöhnt und ich finde,
das war gar nicht mal so falsch, wie das funktioniert.
Das würde ich verteidigen wollen tatsächlich.
Wenn du zwischen mehreren Fenstern
einer oder einer Fenster...
Ja, ich weiß, was dein Argument ist,
als ich erstelle.
Also ich würde das Problem, was du da mit den Fenstern hast,
hast du ja wahrscheinlich erst mal mit Spectacle ab.
Ja, genau.
Aber das macht keinen besseren Windows-Switcher.
Nee, aber du kannst das Fenster wieder reinholen.
Du kannst das Fenster wieder reinholen.
Ja, ja, das mache ich.
Da hast du natürlich irgendwie 35 unterschiedliche Kombinationen
von Control-Shift und Control-Command und Alt-Command.
Die wichtigsten hat man im Master-Memory.
Da bin ja auch alle umgemerkt auf was ich schön finde.
Aber was ich mal hatte mit Multiple Monitoren,
was ich ganz schrecklich fand, ist, ich hatte lange Zeit
einen 4K-Monitor daheim, den ich als Hauptmonitor
genutzt habe. Da war auch dann dementsprechend
der Dock und die Menu Bar drauf.
Das Witzige, was ich mal hatte,
als ich das Ding im Pivot-Modus umgeschaltet habe,
auf so 90 Grad gedreht habe,
im Hochkant-Modus, plötzlich
hat der sich neu ausgerichtet,
in dem Sinne, dass die Monitore nicht mehr
nebeneinander waren, sondern
an den Ecken zusammenhängen.
Und dass der Dialog
für, also du weißt ja, wenn du
Monitore so anordnest, kannst du nur an bestimmten Kanten
mit dem Mauszeiger raus und du kamst über die Ecke
nicht rüber. Das heißt, der Mauszeiger war gefangen
auf einem Monitor, aber das Fenster,
die Systemeinstellung für die Monitoranordnung
auf dem anderen.
Wenn du Monitore so anordnest, dass da Luft
dazwischen ist, kommst du mit der Maus nicht?
Nein, die Luft geht nicht, aber die waren an der Ecke.
An der Spitze von der Ecke hat macOS die irgendwie
als Fallback zusammenurte. Du kamst mit dem Mauszeiger
nicht durch die Ecke durch. Der war kein Pixel,
wo du durchkommst. Und ich kam
an diesen Dialog nicht ran, weil der war auf dem
einer Monitor im Ausdruck aus dem anderen gefangen.
Ich fühle mich so dumm.
Okay, alt auf eins, dann kriegst du
das.
Ich habe wieder rausgezogen.
Hoffen, dass es in dem Monitor passiert.
Rausgezogen, umgedreht, 90 Grad reingesteckt
und nochmal. Dann waren wir ja alles in Ordnung.
Das war einfach so, wie kann ich das lösen?
Was ist hier kaputt? Ich konnte nicht rüber.
Ja, solche Sachen.
Oh Mann.
Okay, das war jetzt nochmal eine halbe Stunde
Zusatzgelaber. Wollen wir weitermachen?
Soll ich das jetzt nachträglich rausschneiden, was ich gerade erzähle?
Oder wollen wir Schluss machen?
Ich würde eigentlich gerne schließen,
vor der Weihnachtszeit, da können wir den Leuten
noch ein schönes Gefühl mitgeben.
Wir müssen ja nicht unbedingt nur ein kaputtes
was auch immer reden.
Das war eigentlich die letzte Folge, die wir dieses Jahr veröffentlichen, oder?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Also ich meine, wenn du dir unsere Frequenz
anguckst.
Krass.
2017, wir hatten dieses Jahr angefangen.
Wir hätten mal einen Jahresrückblick machen können.
Über Akronomie Sieber oder was?
allgemein? Vielleicht
können wir das in einer anderen Folge machen.
Okay, machen wir nächstes Jahr. Genau.
Also wir wünschen euch
Happy Holidays.
Merry Christmas.
Achso, vielleicht können wir das voraussagen.
Wir waren, den wir gerade erwähnt haben.
Also wir beide zumindest, Kilian und ich, werden auf dem Kongress sein.
Wirst du auf dem Kongress sein? Ich bin auf jeden Fall auch mit dabei.
Ja, da werden wir gerade auf dem Kongress sein.
Also, wenn ihr uns hört,
okay, es gibt Leute, die uns hören, krass.
Und dann
sagt uns doch mal auf dem Kongress,
Wir werden dann rechtzeitig auf Twitter
wahrscheinlich noch veröffentlichen, wo ihr uns auf dem Kongress finden werdet.
Mich werdet ihr ziemlich sicher auf dem Rust Assembly finden.
Mich werdet ihr überall finden.
Ich werde nur durch die Gegend wandern.
Ich werde mich nirgendwo hinstellen für leer als zwei Minuten.
Ich werde mit meiner
blauen Jutetüte mit dem Rust-Logo rumlaufen.
Daran werdet ihr mich wahrscheinlich erkennen.
Also sagt uns noch mal
Heil auf dem Kongress.
Und ansonsten
guten Rutsch. Wir sehen uns dann
nächstes Jahr wieder.
Sehr cool. Bin gespannt.
Das war die erste Folge mit einem Bonus-Track.
Aber jetzt, ohne zu lügen,
nächste Folge in eurem Podcatcher beginnt.
Also, in 3, 2, 1...